bienvenue à sans filtre le podcast on
parle lorsqu'on veut que nous inviter
dati si tu perds quand un cadeau mme
plante
aujourd'hui on a reçu au podcast nicolau
ouellette qui animateurs que vous avez
peut-être vu à od plus en direct mais
également à l'émission à radio-canada la
radio de radio canada l'émission fit du
bruit qui est excellente
également un gars qui touche à peine
afaki gérant d'artistes qui le gérant de
philippe brac
on a parlé de son parcours de comment il
fait pour être aussi
talentueux et être aussi intéressé à
toutes sortes de choses aussi
diversifiée on a parlé de hip hop
américain le toujours en plein de sujets
et une belle rencontre l'égoïsme pas
sympathique ispa gentil particulier
alors que du plaisir
ouais le podcast aujourd'hui présentée
par vegan n'est pas plate de livres de
recettes 100% vegan de moins ma copine
est ce que sur la nature du reste gelé
même pas demander mieux
ouais je te donnais où tu peux te le
procurer quatre garçons vous reçoit ce
trophée c'est l'fun d'avoir menacé
ouais parfait si liberté si vous voulez
vous vous procurez vous aussi vous
pouvez utiliser le code promo podcast 20
dans le lien écrit dans la description
de la vidéo pour sauver 20% sur le livre
de recettes comment donc pas de casque
vin facile pas vu un le livre le ilbo
ségolène bowie
[Rires]
sinon vous pouvez vous abonner à la
chaîne youtube de podcasts pour pas
manquer un podcast qui sortent toutes
les mardis les signes ou des
commentaires on aime se voulait on aime
ce interagir avec vous sur ce mont poker
salut salut bienvenus les boys
merci d'avoir accepté de venir ça
plaisait vraiment super contente d'être
une figure qui est que l'homme est
apparu un petit peu dans le dans le
showbiz dans la télé principalement avec
aude et plus on dirait que j'imagine va
changer ta vie un petit peu le show biz
mais ce que ça a changé ma vie
c'est une bonne question non public te
découvres exact et je pense que ce
serait la meilleure affirmation
j'étais un peu seul objectif aussi dans
le fait de faire ça parce que ça quand
même
une roue du temps au niveau du contenu
c'est quand même différent de ce qu'on
était mieux de te voir budget c'est plus
light mais tout aussi amusante et
l'autre h talas soir est encore jeune
avec nathalie petrowski pis elle m'a
posé une question par abbas était en
fait la question classique que tout le
monde me poser depuis les jeux ne sait
trop combien derniers mois depuis
juillet a été annoncé c'est pourquoi tu
fais ça j'ai l'impression que les gens
oublient c'est quoi faire le métier que
moi c'est moi je veux dire a la base je
suis un comédien je suis pas un
humoriste
gg je suis pas un influenceur ma job
pour peu importe ce que ça veut dire la
très influente et mon métier le métier
que j'ai appris depuis que j'ai 15 ans
et d'animer puis à nîmes une geek comme
ceux une quotidienne quatre soirs par
semaine en direct ça existe une envie
non pas que nonobstant le contenu puis
moi j'ai pas de problème avec le contenu
qu'on fait parce que je pense qu'on la
borde la bonne façon mais nonobstant ce
que les gens pensent du contenu c'est à
quoi il faut y réfléchissez au fait que
moi je peux faire mon métier dans ce
contexte mais oui exactement pourtant
bon défi paraît parce que des fois les
libres bis égard il faut que tu ramènes
ce que je trouve drôle c'est souvent les
gens parlaient away tenir le plateau
psychique ses salades je sais c'est
soutenir un plateau s'y tient pas un
plateau t'anime potes en vie les a fait
ça pour toi même pour prendre des photos
de thé qui depuis pour profiter du
standing que la job done sans faire la
job elle-même ouais ça sert à rien
bonjour et puis ça va être compliqué
quand même justement de d'apprendre à
gérer avec à chaque semaine de nouveaux
mondes puisque ces titres jamais
vraiment de repères par rapport à
comment ces gens là vont agir tu peux tu
essaies de la télé qui t'en dirai bas en
direct sur le plateau est réellement
c'est vraiment direct je pense que
autre chose à laquelle les gens pensent
pas c'est que la ferai constante d'une
équipe de télé s'est jamais les gens qui
sont vains c'est les gens qui sont
derrière que témoin les gens sur qui je
m'appuie les gens qui me donnent des
balises qui sont mes bouts et c'est
vraiment c'est carola voit la
productrice au contenu c'est madeleine
quentin la productrice et ls bord du à
la recherchiste maintenant le monteur
sait capter du plessis qui fait notre
web avec anne-marie l'habite combat
c'est toute cette équipe là c'est
sylvain elle assiste real ses pattes le
real c'est mélanie de cobra moi c'est
tous ces gens là qui sont la vraie
constante de l'équipe c'est sûr que moi
à la base que je m'appuie parce que du
moment où on est en ondes le sait la
plus petite infime part du travail qui
ces 20 minutes du lundi au mercredi
ces 43 minutes le dimanche ouais c'est
rien toi tu habites ces deux journées
extrêmement longue ça finit [ __ ] mais
quand tu arrives 20 minutes et naruto la
beauté du direct au site du magazine
longtemps j'imagine que je me refais
aventure guigue parce que quelqu'un peut
faire un bon on va la refaire
c'était parfait voilà pourquoi es tu es
tu pas pourquoi mais ouais c'est ça
c'est qu'en direct peut pas reprendre ce
qui s'est dit peu importe rendre les
mamans qui vivent ça nous dédouane aussi
les affres plutôt est ce qu est ce que
c'était quelque chose que quitte à 6-6
de donner l'aubade est comme un poisson
dans l'eau au puits en général je suis
toujours stressé la première fois quand
j'ai commencé le show de radio à
radio qu'amiens un an et quelqu'un
quelques semaines
c'est la première qui me stresse si la
première fois bien que si j'ai
l'impression d'être embarqué dans un air
d'aller dont les vues sont les
frontières sont claires mais qui vont
aller dans une housse je sais que je
vais pouvoir développer en un sens ce
qui est constant partir de ce point le
jeu devient plus nerveux tant que ça
après mais la première fois ci c'est
vraiment très simple surtout commencé
avec un dimanche
od +10 commence avec un dimanche c'est
une heure avec du monde que tu connais
pas avec ce monde qui te connaissent pas
non plus pitt et moi j'arrivais là
dedans dit ya quand même des choses
claires
j'anime jeu là pour tenir un plateau
pour respecter le timing pour m'arranger
pour que ce soit fluide quel contenu
passe pour être la colle en tout le
monde mais comme je voulais dit en tout
c'est moi je suis pas un humoriste
active mon objectif c'est pas des trous
devint bétonner la partie quand même six
mois je me voyais pas arriver puis
prendre portée des segments à katie
essayé d'être drôle volontairement en
ayant quelqu'un qui écrit des blagues
pour moi ça me va me parler pas équipés
des chroniques pour les luttes j'écris
pas de chrono en fait j'écris pop
comment on travaille c'est qu'on va voir
un document de paix c'est à dire le thé
les faillites en touche pas les deux
quarts où elle risque sont au contenu
vont faire le déroulement de l'épisode
moi je vais lire les déroulements de
l'épisode on va sans jason ensemble
c'est des fois je refais ramos bloc
l'homme semble que je mettrais seul tell
tale telle chose qu'on va aborder je
perçois que c'est bon là la poutine
malgré tout ce que je fais c'est que moi
je me mets quelques mots clés je sais
comment j'en vois la peau je sais
comment je revienne la pause
je sais c'est quoi les éléments visuels
qu'on n'a pas le choix d'envoyer en
nombre parce que ça reste la télé mais
le reste est tout étant mouvance puis
chante comme une occasion avec caro qui
me parle d'en monter les ex pillon sur
celui-là potsdam pharma job si j'étais
pris dans un carcan de texte je serais
pas heureux
puis est ce que le plus grand défi c'est
justement que koné vite et sa chronique
à fit dans le quatre minutes que trop de
blocs
oui pinotti ça reste quand même flexible
déchets ou des si je faisais la
comparaison par exemple avec ce qu'on
fait nous à la radio en direct vendredi
à radio calme à tout comme si tout le
monde dans l'équipe préparé quelque
chose qui fait qu'on a du contenu pré
produit on sait la durée on sait qu'on a
53 minutes et on sait qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de contenu qu'on n'a
pas le choix d'aborder l'action c'est
vraiment un défi pour moi mon année de
tenir le temps de faire ne viendrait pas
de ça ou bon ok c'est bon on va y aller
ça croyant un peu plus de temps pour ça
concernant cas rod été abandonnée que tu
fais une affaire opposant front
comprends tu le dis toi que je parle du
6e fringe demain pezi ou pas c'est pas
très grave
la chaussée plus que sur la table ses
chansons et a annoncé ça mais il ya
comme pissier déclaré qu'ils lèvent
qu'ils sont drôles
il veut quand il veut bien précis avec
caro on prend la décision qu est-ce qu
on coupe qu'est ce qu'on regarde souvent
moi je préfère qu'on coupe dans le temps
que moi je rêve c'est pas pour des
présenter le show de revenir d'une pause
pour faire une entrevue avec quelqu'un
que de couper dans la chronique des gens
qui sont préparés pendant plusieurs
heures pour venir faire rire le monde
c'est ça l'objectif de bastos était
d'amener la satire dans ce concept lucky
de trouver l'amour
puis je suis moi j'étais les craintes
car premièrement en fait j'écoute
beaucoup plus facilement au début c'est
maintenant qu'on n'est pas fan mais
aussi je trouve que tout amène une
ambiance que moi je préfère peut-être à
l'an passé mais tous étant dit les
chroniqueurs heureux pour se préparer
une chronique pour qu'ils écoutent
tellement attentivement tout kerry
écoute
est ce que toutes prêtes au même jeu que
moi j'écoute les épisodes une fois en
mars qui n'a pas besoin d'avoir le petit
reaction de faire un montage et surtout
tu es ma posture c'est vraiment d'être
le conduit entre la personne qui écoute
aux dés ce qui se passe sur notre
plateau mexique moi je me mets à
analyser puis sur analyser les choses je
suis pas dans la perspective de maxime
ou et
alice qui ont écouté le cheval soit
mangé une soupe puis qui veulent avoir
la réaction qui ont eu des réactions
spontanées en regardant chaud mois faut
que je reste dans cette posture la
presse est évident que moi je sais ce
que les gens vont faire et je veux avoir
une analyse qui va être différent parce
que je n'écoute pas aussi dans le même
contexte que vont faire mais j'ai pas
dans l'analyse que vont faire pression
sur des collaborateurs les mécanismes
qu'ils ont c'est un guillaume pineau par
exemple sa marque des choses qui étaient
là pour marquer ces débats je regarde
les choses je me dis ah ça c'est sûr que
pino va sauter même s'ils sont là dessus
c'est un puis deux puis trois puis
quatre niveaux de plus mais moi j'aurais
imaginé au départ c'est vraiment bon ces
belles découvertes
je les croisais j'avais un événement au
festi jeunes a cité à la baie au
saguenay et là je me pointe la pythie
moi j'étais pour aller faire une
conférence sur mon parcours d'athlète
puis après sur un atelier de création de
terreur puis lui ce point mais moi je
n'avais pas encore à ce moment là
écoutez les eaux déplaçant dirai pas ce
que je vais technion guardian peary vif
et le team je le connais je le reconnais
pas justice à qui puis finalement je
parle un peu petit m'explique que le lui
avait choqué le shopi avait travaillé là
dessus mais finalement j'ai écouté et
photos un numéro 2 de 45 minutes
cet effet dit il voire 500 personnes
finalement il y avait une salle qui
devait pas pouvoir remplir plus que 100
personnes y avait trente jeunes que vous
attire à lui il me regardait alors que
je modifie mon numéro parce que des
blagues qui était pas vraiment pas
d'appliquer au monde
c'est ça la job du monde devenir usant
une chance guillaume sangoï un peu qui à
mon sens m le monde pour vrai poème est
passionné de son métier
moi je respecte les gens aussi qui sont
passés par autre chose avant d'être
arrivé à ce métier artistique françois
bellefeuille mme guillot et s'est dit
lui disant l'université finalement mon
ami a fait moi ma vie c'est de faire de
l'humour pour que ça leur donne une
perspective qu'un rapport relationnel
humain qui est vraiment différent que
l'humoriste qui rentre à l'école à 19
ans que juge pas nouveau mais que
peut-être une perspective une relation
avec les métiers qui est différent
intéressant peut-être aussi que l'humour
est pour le moins ce que quelqu'un par
exemple qui apprend à écrire pas à
l'école dans un contexte et parce que on
s'entend que plusieurs endroits par
exemple lire cela va les autres qui ont
un carcan assez précis les tirs dont le
jeu par le monde au même l'impression de
terrain avec le monde qui sort de l'eau
ont appris à écrire un petit peu de la
même façon appris les techniques de
travail qu'un semblable sort de quelque
chose d'autre et une autre perspective
je sais pas les apprentissages scolaires
comme apprendre les tic puis la
structure mais thibault pour reprendre
ces clichés a quand même l'idée que
apprendre des règles tu les as prend
pour ensuite les défendrons type les
explique fu qui comprend bien tu
d'exemple je pense qu'ils en humour
aussi tellement une démocratisation du
métier une démocratisation du drôle
aussi dans les dernières années on a
tous ces exemples en tête mais tant
julien lacroix qui est jamais allé à
l'école
c'est la preuve même que t'as pas besoin
nécessairement de connaître les règles
et mécanismes les avoir appris pendant
deux ans puis rodez dans un système
standard pour que le monde se trouve
drôle une éthique de travail
c'est aussi celle du mot c'est aussi
d'observer la vie de tous les jours puis
trouver d'aider les choses de ce qu'on
prend pour acquis mais qu'ils sont
drôles sont absurdes ceux qui justement
d'avoir fait un autre métier avance ça
donne des expériences de vie que tu te
poses ton était en chemin ligne droite
et aller à l'école parce que juste le
monde avec
cette nuit-là milieu dans lequel a
évolué et c'est sûr que si on reste
toujours dans un cirque qui est le même
et puis souvent que c'est un truc auquel
on pense
une chose à laquelle on pense beaucoup
le mot canton particulièrement la radio
tu en vois souvent amené des sujets ou
des perspectives sur des sujets où un
moment donné faut qu'on fasse elle tient
on est vraiment dans notre chambre
d'écho ce à dire que tu sais juste nous
autres et les les jeunes artistes et
animateurs chroniqueurs avec des
perspectives soum anti libéral de gauche
qui pensons que c'est un sujet important
qui pensons que les gens savent
exactement partout au même point que
nous dit je pense que dans la job aussi
d'animations il ya toujours ce site
c'est à dire c'est quoi le point de
départ de la majorité des gens qui
regardent qu'on est en train de faire en
ce moment
selon la chaîne selon le propos selon le
contexte selon l'heure c'est ce point de
départ lui il va toujours changer team
est important de toujours se reposer la
question que j'ai l'impression que
souvent peu importe confirme à prendre
pour acquis les connaissances et les
perspectives déjà je pense qu'il faut
souvent en journalisme a même chose pour
en revenir à la base c'est quoi le
contexte qu'il faut que je donne au
monde pour qu'ils comprennent ce dont on
va parler après la même chose quand on
fait une des plus chaudes et plus et
mettons que tu arrives à od plus puis
qui est jamais écouté au des petits
quand même trouvé ça drôle
petit je le sais pas tu vois tu sais
vraiment pas mais si je me dis mettez
les extraits puis vous mettez ça compte
externe
ouais mais si tu peux écouter mais je
vois pas ce qu il faut pour quoi tu
écoutes rsa c'était plutôt des médecins
pensent que tu peux ne pas avoir suivi
l'aventuré coûté un épisode d'une
quotidienne d'eau des couteaux des plus
je trouvais ça très très drôle mais je
pense pas que si t'es jamais
écoutez une quotidienne petit tombe sur
des plus doit faire c'est la même chose
que j'écoutais tout commentaire
mais jacques que tu peux tu ris de
trouver ça drôle quand même te retrouver
sa plus pure plus premier niveau
le tai chi kesha l'est réellement ces
clubs se connaissent les personnages
aussi moi simple l'essentiel la faire
par exemple renault justement tu es
surpris la faire il faut qu'ils
connaissent le personnage un peu
pourquoi pour toi on en est rendu le
nombre d'analystes 2 importe sa personne
a aussi son jeu le groupe qu'on n'a pas
toutes en tant que personnage parce que
c'est vraiment un succès les personnages
on prend des personnes qu on a fait des
personnages du moment où par exemple
d'homme je filme sa vie pendant 24
heures que je l' ai dit en 30 minutes
et oui jean caricature de toi je
garderai pas les moments où tu es assis
en train de réfléchir tout doucement ou
décrire tes pensées le ce point
intéressant genou pour garder ce nous
regarder le moment type est une coche au
livreur de pizza qui est morte a aussi
trouvé l'adresse c'est cela vient laisse
la rage et conclut rouzier exact je leur
fais tout le temps des grossistes n'ont
jamais alors c'est la rumeur qui court
jusqu'à nicolas côté classique
oui mais c'est clair c'est clair que ça
fait seuls les montages puis je vais
revenir à ce que tu disais plus avant
sur en fait du phénomène de bain c'est
le phénomène des bulles l'affrontement
que le tipi comment on fait pour pour
avoir la perspective extérieur t'invite
françois lambert ton podcast c'est parce
qu'une commande
ennui françois lambert site sebi
politiquement probablement qu'on n'est
vraiment pas l'opposé mais on est loin
certains moins suspecte pitié cd
je prends tout résident est le tenant
c'est difficile de décider d'essayer
d'aller voir qu'est ce qui est utile
sans penser qu'ils insultent et une
tendance populaire aussi je fais juste
me fier à - pièce que je vois mettons
ces réseaux sociaux trump il y aurait
une personne qui votent pour lui il
était danseur
sauf que world of cyprus la réalité
s'est passé absolument passer sur les
jeunes yéyés là le problème
petit mais il ya plein d'aspects à cette
question là
maintenant qu'on parle de tram'tiss
comme une situation intéressante puisque
justement ce matin en maintenant c'est
tous les matins j'écoute le podcast déry
du new york times si ce modèle parlé de
l'importance de considérer les
populations rurales dans les sondages
pendant la façon dont ça a changé la
perspective du vote dans les dernières
méthodes et puis je pense qu'en fait le
problème il est ici qu on veut toujours
[Musique]
adoptez la perspective qui qui nous
convient
je pense toujours avoir des
conversations qui vont entrer en général
on avoir des conversations qui m'ont ici
nous conforter dans nos propres usines
je pense que c'est vraiment content et
de faire le point
de prendre la décision dans une journée
qui écourte qui va vite qui est
compliqué la vie c'est compliqué moi je
voulais mon désir ah ben je vais prendre
une heure ou deux le problème farcir un
lent grid
ouais écrit petit non seulement qui
traite de mai écrite par quelqu'un qui
adopte une perspective par exemple de
vraiment compliqué parce que c'est
confrontant tabarouette le lire ces
affaires le puits après sijsling chemise
golo apport raison ouais c'est ça la
course comprend la page
justement le 6 par rapport à nos propres
perspectives qui oppose raison mais faut
aller plus loin que ça pour comprendre
c'est quoi les mécanismes
l'investissement un investissement de
temps et d'énergie c'est la meilleure
manière d'apprendre argumenté de
connaître les contre arguments mais sauf
que souvent on va se concentrer sur lui
on va se concentrer sur le contre
argumentaire plutôt que son entrée sur
l'idée de comprendre l'argumentaire des
trucs pour ensuite l'intellectuel y
faire
qu'est ce que j'en pense c'est comment
je peux répondre à cette histoire se
concentraient en disant c'est pas vrai
il ya par exemple à ce dossier de
comprendre pourquoi lui selon lui viole
puisqu à autant de gaza sont attirés par
ce qu'il doit avoir une certaine logique
interne qui fait qu'ils essaient de la
halle à votre bon sens parce qu'il les a
pas écoutés ces gens-là lendemain c'est
clair aujourd'hui en droit de prendre la
parole
c'est une grappe ils font ils bon avec
leurs croyances que personne n'en a
parlé il ya peu de dialogues tu es
souvent on écoute pour contre argumenter
on n'écoute pas pour écouter on aime ou
on écoute pour répondre points et on
écoute et on va avoir une conversation
puis vidé à partir de partir du moment
où on a compris le point central de ce
que la personne était en train de dire
on est en train de se dire comment je
peux balancer là-dessus et c'est comme
ça qu'on nous apprend les interactions
conversationnel dans la vie à mon sens
c'est pour ça que j'ai très mal à l'aise
avec la conversation fatigués de juste
faire et ça vaut oui il fait beau dehors
maintenant parce que je le suis quand on
fait juste banc d'essai pour essayer
puis essayer de faire avancer le temps
je sois jamais une conversation avec une
amie qui m'a dit tu vois c'est de la
mauvaise façon c'est comme des buildings
c'est à dire que au lieu de te dire à
une conversation qui est vraiment
surface en ce moment dit toi qui est en
train de mettre les fondations pour
aller vers l'élévation de ton niveau de
conversation
ça m'a fait réfléchir quand même ce que
moi je suis peut être le genre de
personne qui aux dépens d'une
conversation enfin je suis pas intéressé
je suis plus intéressé par mon discours
interne à la conversation que j'ai avec
moi c'est vrai que c'est inutile
certaines mais c'est ce qui est qui est
beau avec la radio avec les podcasts
niveau depuis qu'on fait si c'est que
skip certaines étapes
aussi quand ils se sont tous un
traitement dans le vif du sujet ce qui
fait que justement ces deux montants
claude tu n'as pas besoin et puis
qui ça fait quand 2 arte va connaître
quelqu'un tellement plus que tu leur ai
connu en deux ans au resto avec os qu'il
ya du bruit ou est-ce que tu parle un
peu de la surface petit c'est la beauté
du cadre
ça monte de l'objectif clair de créer
par exemple pas de casse de conversation
comme vous faites
tu le sais moi je sais pourquoi je suis
l'oeuvre vous savez prendre un vous le
faites
effectivement comme tu le dis on sort
d'un des étapes de la conversation
normale dans la vie parce que souvent
quand une conversation avec quelqu'un
malheureusement vu plus on vieillit je
trouve que c'est comme ça plus tu
demandes
ce que tu peux retirer de la personne
pas quelque chose que je me demande
souvent mais j'aimerais sentiment que
les gens se demandent qu'est ce qu'ils
peuvent retirer deux mois - qu'est-ce
qu'ils peuvent retirer de la
conversation qui va leur servir dans le
futur
ok je suis comment la conversation
utilitaires mais je pense que plus on
vieillit plus faut faire attention à se
donner un sens utile à tout ce qu'on
fait moi je coupable de ce n'est pas
utilisée dans un sans-faute dans un
cocktail puis le legend part parce que
nicolas où elle est mais regarde autour
c'est pas quelqu'un plus big et qui
parlait si je pense que c'est l'exemple
le plus je veux dire vulgaire ton
exemple bulgare mais je voudrais le plus
absurde sont caricaturales mais je pense
que même dans des interactions très très
normal c'est de la fiq et je trouve que
beaucoup de ceux ci y ait beaucoup de
steed et l'aude
je sais je sais pas qui m'a même des
fois tu parles du monde
par exemple la radio le choix radio
quand des fois je parle à des gens que
je me rends compte que je chanterai
loisirs
quelle histoire cette personne l'homme
raconte ferait un bon segment de radio
comme ans que j'entraîne vivent en ce
moment peut par exemple se convertir en
quelque chose que je vais écrire pour
mon essai d'un trou dans ce disque on
pense que les mondanités de tout le
temps la pensée utilitaire dans ta tête
tu sais que tu me le cynisme chez pas la
curiosité ce serait de les contacter
yves complète
ouais c'est ça
mais ça mais en même temps si tu fais
seulement de les contacter yves complexe
et difficile d'utiliser la conversation
à 2 pour propulser la discussion vers un
autre niveau un peu c'est une personne
discours elle-même seul un monologue la
conversation va - s'élever à part moi je
pense que le choc des idées sur un
mécanisme pour faire avancer la
conversation
du point de vue qu'on s'écoute picon que
c'est pas du monologue et par aline ça
ça arrive souvent de gros séismes très
régulier presse
mais c'est intéressant le point que tu
disais par rapport au fix souvent qu'un
qu'on commence à parler puis moi aussi
je suis coupable de sur suivant cas
qu'on commence à parler avec quelqu'un
qu'on connaît pas par le smart tank
rapidement moi je me dis cette
conversation là m'intéressent pas non
elle m'intéresse moins que comme tu dis
mon discours interne puis ça ça fait que
j'ai l'impression qu'on doit passer à
côté beaucoup de discussions
qui aurait le potentiel qui aurait du
potentiel c'est ouais je sais pas si
c'est lié à quoi peut-être c'est un jeu
c'est pas ça a toujours été comme ça ou
si maintenant avec l'avancement de la
technologie rapide du web d'information
rapide on prend plus le temps vraiment
d'avoir ces discussions là parce que je
pense que nos sources d'information
russe 1 sont diverses et deuxièmement
nous nos canaux de conversation sont
encore plus multiples 10000 le giron
sans talons fait de la balade les
chevaux des de l'entrepôt de la sociaux
à 200 petit je me dis qu'à l'époque où
tu avais pas la botte l'opportunité
d'aller converser avec ton meilleur ami
sur ton celle du moment où tu avais une
conversation une interaction plus ou
moins intéressants j'imagine que tu
avais peut-être un effort de plus à
faire pour eux de choisir vivre le
moment présent au moins être incarnée
dans la conversation était en train
d'avoir déjà vous commandez foi peut
avoir l'opportunité mais voilà qu'il est
il maintenant croiser quelqu'un dans un
bus qui est en mode et il ya des gens
comme ça qui sont en mode conversation
ouais enfin bon jour nonobstant que tu
sois connu ou politiques qui vont le
savoir en vie de converser ouais non
plus commenter quelque chose que tu es
en train de faire ou en train de lire
puis le réflexe suivant c'est de faire à
oui c'est ça c'est très bon sens est
méchant mais juste de fermer la porte
complètement dans cette possible
interaction le thé des fois je me dis et
mettons qu'on laissait le mettons que je
pige pas le réflexe de faire est chaude
dans cette conversation leur puis je
vais aller par là mon meilleur ami pour
dire et mène une madame doit parler dans
le bus ce que je fais je vois la vie
puis je l'aï raconté après je suis sûr
que notre perspective par rapport à
cette interaction le changerait
complètement que c'est sûr je suppose
que non plus mais s'intéresse en deux
fois par les verts c'est ce qu'on ferait
à l'habitude c'est était de prendre le
métro toujours par brique pilée tu
marches au dessus juste pour changer la
perspective que d'habitude gates et de
sa défaite et des mécanismes justement
qui sont intégrés était des fois quand
on vend voyage je me sens est arrivé
mais par exemple est dépassé j'ai passé
l'été à new york
pis
tout seul fait
je peux être une autre personne je peux
aller m'asseoir dans un bar en face de
mon appart parler à quelqu'un que je
connais pas je peux aller tout seul
faire telle activité
tu change la perspective plus tu
reviennes en tes pantoufles qui fait
rage voir a mené seule cette philosophie
mais je pense que tu la philosophie
voyage dans la vie de tous les jours on
que ce soit même découvrir la ville où
peu importe la beauté du voyage ces
voyages ont été dans la vie tous les
jours on se définit beaucoup parce qu'on
fait c'est pas notre merci ou parce que
mais le cantal et tout ça en voyage
c'est juste tu es juste toi il est juste
là l'individu pour le tout le construit
que pardus qui fait que ça fait du bien
première lampe se fait vive ça fait voir
le monde à travers une nouvelle
perspective qui complémentent pin mois
les plus beaux voyages effet pied notre
pain pour le voyage à notre vie c'est un
voyage que de voyage on a fait un voyage
en république dominicaine
un voyage en asie à taïwan qui c'est
vraiment con métier on avait une
victoire contre la république n'avait 21
dans le fond le ces voyages c'était
c'était quand même particulier parce
qu'on a un ami qui est étudiante en
médecine et la faculté de médecine
organisé un voyage pour les étudiantes
et de la recherche de l'association à
ses 60 ans et 6 ans qui pour ceux qui
voulaient un voyage d études en médecine
bon tacle et y étaient 25 ayari qui il
restait quelques places pour avoir une
espèce de prix des deux groupes le t2
avantageux fac lyon ouvert aux amis
notre ami alexandre nous dit ça vous
tombe dessus devenir moi php nom de nos
amis fils ce qu'ils ont on avait comme
rien semaine de hockey
on y voit pourquoi poti semaine dans le
sud vraiment lutté tout inclus vraiment
énorme
là c'est vraiment c'est dit
vraiment les sur papier lester comme
acquis en tête les titres au sol gauche
finalement c'est le batteur puis les
vins des titans médecin c'est juste des
filles passaient sans nallet le
pistaient comme acquis le savoir happy
hours un papier sur papier de diop a dit
avoir vu quelque chose de d'incroyable
finalement le voyage a pas été ce qu'on
aurait pensé qu'ils étaient à juste
rencontré 20 nouvelles personnes
intéressant qui avons rien d'autre à
faire que parler d'être sa plage
pizzetti sert à ça ça arrive jamais
jamais quitté je suis venu ce voyage le
tellement socialement alès moi qui suis
pas la personne et puisards et
socialement qui le c'était comme j'avais
développé pendant une semaine une autre
affaire un muscle dans le temps j'avais
encore un flip phone que j'avais laissé
à la maison que j'avais été j'avais
aucune technologie la bulle
c'est une semaine de désintox total a
juste converser
c'est vraiment le voyage qui m'a le plus
changé 1 qui mène ce contexte si en
italie justement tu allais à taiwan en
somme on a vu des à partie et on a vu
une autre planète carré marché des
voyages touquet seul lot un tout inclus
en république dominicaine c'était comme
une révélation à mettet de cesser les
plus beaux moments quand de l'ordinaire
surgisse l'exceptionnel 1 mettra ça sur
un fond de coucher de soleil vers des
stations expirant tâche est rude mais
pas chaque jour non mais c'est parce
qu'en fait ce conflit est ce pas
compliqué c'est qu'en fait c'est quand
je lis des trucs particulièrement tu es
dans des livres dans des romans ou quand
je vais juste pour écouter des entrevues
td longue points soit il ya des moments
pour moi qui vont me saisit pas tango de
citations je crois pas de citations je
crois pas ça mais je pense que quand tu
quand 'le contexte autour pic est une
citation qui tape pense que c'est bon
parce que ça te ramène oui à l'idée même
de ce que tous notés mais ça tu ramènes
aussi au contexte non autour mettez des
fois je suis peut noter des pages
entières lettres comprendre d'une
entrevue que j'ai entendu ou des fois
c'est juste une phrase ça dépend ça
dépendra peut-être toujours en train
d'exercer ton cerveau en train de
réfléchir en train de développer des
idées
ben si j'avais arrêté je le sais c'est
dur c'est dur quand tu es dans ta tête
de tir le moi je le fais pas de façon
consciente moi j'ai l'impression
j'ai pas beaucoup de pros je pense je
m'offre pas beaucoup de pauses
je pense que oui parce que je suis tout
le temps en train de réfléchir à ce que
tu as toujours été comme ça ouais je
pense que oui depuis que tu es tout y
était tout le temps stimuler du post
toujours la réflexion plus loin d'avoir
été je suis passé j'ai déjà raconté ça
me motive mon père c'est l'homme le ça
était l'homme le plus patient au monde
de basket tous les soirs presque dans ma
jeunesse
yves natiembé rebond bonne nuit clash
disait attendant temps puis le jus poser
une question
sur la philosophie universel alors
pourquoi je suis le pourquoi la terre
pourquoi d'affaires vraiment dit mais
mon père comme on dit en anglais ont
négligé jamais chaillot et de cette
conversation le thillay pas un seul
moment où il fait et le pauvre à sword
c'est de même passé de même bonne nuit
puis fait que je pense que
steed et le de pas nécessairement avoir
une réponse concrète à tous mais
d'accepter de la chercher ça a vraiment
influencé la façon dont je réfléchis à
la vie ou à ma job
aujourd'hui on en a déjà parlé sur
podcast avec et avec les autres et les
enfants c'est des êtres immensément
curieux nos philosophes qu'il faut
nourrir puis souvent ce qui arrive c'est
que tu aimes année justement terminé on
est indications pillon on t'arrête
d'imposer le tchad d'armes par le
pragmatisme très dangereux on créera
paul deuxième monde avec des enfants qui
on apprend qu'il ya un corps qui n'ont
cessé que ça arrive trop souvent les les
règles strictes à suivre à l'école ouais
même si moi j'ai toujours beaucoup de
temps avec ce témoin je me rappelle
encore clairement on avait une création
de compositions écrites à faire en 3e
année du primaire pistait 250 mots qu'il
fallait écrire
j'avais écrit que 1500 mots j'avais une
mauvaise note à cause que j'avais pas
respecté la consigne mais
mon histoire des créatifs unis pour être
trop peu créatif fameux nombre de mots
tu fais pas pour le fait pas pour les
jambes sous ma mère était prof est que
je le comprends mais je suis aussi tu es
entrain job difficile c'est son passé
c'est sale affaire aussi ce qui est dur
c'est de punir un enfant qui respectent
pas les règles mais en même temps tu of
paul chaque fois que j'ai vu le match à
travailler à partir de chez nous à 7h
revenait de l'école à 4 qui a passé sa
soirée à faire la correction c'est comme
ça tous les jours bien travaillé les
fins de semaine les gens ont
l'impression que les profs sont sur une
freeride parce qu'ils ont des des
vacances l'été de six mois je n'ai
entendu souvent le par rapport au moment
où m et i ta main à deux mois de
vacances
premièrement je suis allé voir son
salaire
deuxièmement veux tu vois tout l'extra
time qui est fait à la maison pour
lequel et peu payée bakhti je pense que
dans le contexte dont on parle c'est ce
qui est sûr c'est que si tous les
enfants sont dans la liberté des preuves
d'adn mais je pense que je pense que
c'est la tuque ma mère était bonne aussi
c'est foutu comprennent la spécificité
de l'enfant que tu en fasses suprême ce
qui est du seul à faire quand tu te
rends tu aurais un prof pour chaque
élève parce que chaque élève avait
besoin prodigue les attitudes
différentes si ça peut pas être si ça
c'est que l'école aussi quitté le chu de
0,1 spéciale est ce que je peux en fait
à travers mon chapeau mais de
l'expérience que j'en ai vécu de ce que
j'ai vu avec la job de maman c'est que
l'école ait pas d'acte hâtive à dire que
les enfants
ils vont faire leur truc selon un cadre
précis ainsi des passes de ce cadre le
viaur
je veux dire peu de profs l'homme en
même temps tu es tu es moi paul si vous
êtes un pro forma sont que c'est le
contraire je pense que peu de preuves
qui vont prendre le temps de faire est
enfant le en une période d'étude mais il
n'y a pas envie d'étudier il ya envie de
lire son son seigneur des anneaux qui
lisent son seigneur des anneaux ça reste
de la nourriture pour l'esprit parce que
les preuves vont avoir des fois cette
rigidité le faire tout le monde doit
faire la même chose parce que ça fait du
bien d'être dans le corps je pense c'est
possible c'est possible dit moi j'ai une
amie qui est qui et professeurs qui
constate vraiment les forces et les
faiblesses du système l'opib a dit on
étale à l'époque on veut
l'inclusion si on veut inclure tout le
monde pas que là on inclut des fois
d'aider les élèves avec des trous
d'apprentissage ou avec des difficultés
puis aux autres ça les aide parce que je
comprends aussi l'argument de dire si on
les met tous ensemble de ses premiers
ballons
sauf que
je pense que juste l'idée a fait les
utopies ça serait que chaque enfant
puisse développer son plein potentiel
peu importe ce à quoi philippe le plein
potentiel sont différents d'un à l'autre
puis je dire son pot puis je peux dire
son meilleur ou moins bon mais sont
différents mais est-ce parce que ça
prend les services autour aussi pour
faire de l'accompagnement avec des
enfants plus de difficultés ce que je
trouve étrange par exemple avec le tdah
s'imaginer des amis qui ont les traits
encore des personnes mais c'est ça qu'on
les traite comme des personnes assistait
mme colas scolaire un fonctionnel alors
que c'est zéro non et rosé rousse non
c'est juste une façon d'aborder le
savoir la connaissance à concentration
du président luc moine qui est différent
mais si on exploite qu'on passe sur les
bons boutons c'est sûr que si je te
demande j'imagine de rester une heure et
demi à 6 ans en fait je dis ça je dis
coupable mais jamais des risques et j'ai
jamais ça jamais un trouble à au point
de devoir avoir de l'aide le team et ont
pu y jeter pas hyper actif trouve que
que le trouble d'attention votre coup je
pense l'avoir pillé une force das une
force en plein de données puissent y ait
des difficultés dans d'autres mais ce
sont mes amis les plus créatifs mes amis
le plus créatif
c'est un tirage qui va très bien
aujourd'hui n'a pas toujours été facile
je n'ai presse et tous tes posts non non
non j'habitais j'aimerais ceux ci gèle
les thèses me ferait plaisir
j'aimerais passer l'été ça me fait
plaisir d'en parler même quartier états
unis par activité mettant au niveau de
la curiosité puis d'un magazine et de la
culture pilote savoir non
c'est parce que j'ai pas un trouble mais
c'est en qualité parce que oui
c'est sûr tu vois je me souhaite poser
cette question là l'autre fausse idée a
été vraiment hyper actif
tu penses que j'ai juste une perspective
de l'accomplissement du travail qui est
différente de la majorité des gens
surtout à ce point-ci dans ma vie je
n'ai pas beaucoup de choses qui me font
chier comprend ti exact je les fais dans
ma vie quand j'ai commencé à travailler
mais non il ya des moments où tu te
rends compte que tu penses que tu fais
la chose la plus extraordinaire pour ta
vie ou ta carrière qui le thé drainé pas
été vraiment vraiment fatigué c'est dur
de te lever ou 7 tours de la job ci
comprend pas pourquoi peut être est-ce
que tu prends de recul tu fais une
enfant jeté pop bye bye nord ce contexte
ex en ce moment je travaille six à sept
jours par semaine de façon constante des
comme le yar fallait que je fasse des
trucs affecté bon travail le matin 11
heures après se voir une autre après se
voit audi est vrai ce soir de le
j'allais voir un show ça je rentre chez
nous j'ai travaillé jusqu'à 2h30 du
matin je me couche bien
mais pour moi c'est pas fatigué
montmerle parce que je fais que des
choses qui tente qui me font du bien
fait travailler 7 jours sur 7 août il
faire des treize jours en ligne comme je
le fais régulièrement depuis le début de
l'automne
ça ne me dérange pas parce que je me
fais pas çi timbre ce que j'ai envie de
répondre à ces aspects de
l'hyperactivité du jeu si tu fais des
choses qui te passionne qui te font pas
cheap été capable de t'ecouter est le
type le jour où tu es fatigué belgium
pizza soir mais toute cette bonne foi
mais d'autres étaient vite apparue non
jamais jamais jamais pareil au fait tu
ton petit jogging temps en temps je
m'entraîne away ses jugements sur un
rythme de 8 5 rapports pour le sommeil
c'est mon alimentation aussi c'est
quelque chose qui est importante et je
fais pratiquement attention c'est à dire
que
je pense que c'est le fiu mais bon c'est
ça mais oui mais je suis enfant j'ai
appris à m'écouter qui est pas en 2014
il ya un beau tout jeter je pense j'ai
frôlé le genre de burnout parce que tout
commence si vous prouvez que tu es
capable
c'est sur cette affaire qui sont of
psychologiquement parce qu'ils sont
quand même contre intuitive pitbull 6,7
brûle brûle quand c'est des choses qui
tente
c'est tellement je t'écoute parler puis
c'est tellement une bonne façon de voir
ce souffre de ne pas faire des trucs tu
dois te rendre aux biens je travaille
pour une journée à vichy s'installe mais
c'est la réalité c'est que si ces sites
est juste
à l'aise lorsque tu fais tu es capable
d'écouter le tonton propre rythme moi je
vais jamais dire aux gens s il la
meilleure chose au monde c'est de
travailler ses jours par mois je le fais
ça m'appartient tu veux travailler 25
heures par semaine et le suis juste ton
rythme sur un rythme qui est heureux qui
je pense que mon ami aussi l'idée de
créer de l'utile pour toi pour ton
entourage proche ou pour la société
je m'en fous de l'échelle mais juste
créer un peu dit il je pense que c'est
important
puis tu dis qu'à chaque matin tu te
lèves tu écoutes le pod cadre puis
j'imagine que je consomme beaucoup de
musique aussi j'aimerais que tu
consommes de l'information de l'or au
quotidien dans tes dents times cite pas
l'impression que ce que tu mets ton
cerveau à off des fois est-ce que tu eu
des moments où est ce que tu es couteaux
des messages mais avant ça lui ferait
tout écouté le juge toujours une saison
j'ai pas suivi que parce que j'étais en
transition genre quand charles à
montréal et quelque chose du genre
mais sinon j'ai tout le temps tu
t'écoutes effet cui à les petits moutons
là n'est pas assez moi je vous regarde
et j'étais bon moment au moment où
j'avais dit ça je pense que c'est pour
tout le monde sauf ceux qui sont
impliqués massivement si on peut faire
une parenthèse là dessus parce que ce
qui me fait halluciner
c'est tout ce temps à libre que vous
devez amont sur les mains moi je viens
ce mardi par activité ou en parlant de
ce que dit pas besoin de stimulation
ça me fait capoter mais je veux juste un
mois avant de partir je t'ai je suis
encore en train de la forme et ma
maîtrise en littérature et j'avais à
chaque semaine deux fois trois heures
dans semaine ou est-ce que c'était des
séminaires de maîtrise fait tu t'assois
avec du monde 2e 3e siècle juste pour
avoir des conversations challenge
account
chacun un champ de connaissances ultra
précis les tubes ans des idées comme
ceux de tes lèvres d'addiction t'élève
ton dès la fin des travaux à faire à
chaque semaine tu lis tu es dans un un
mode d'instruction de créativité pis je
recommence à peine à voir semaine
tellement sa momie of pi leur pendant un
an complet c'est que dans un espèce de
tu t'assois devant l'ordi pour écrire de
kouassi de l'est mardi que tu fais si tu
es capable d'écrire dit juste touché à
cause que pendant trois quatre mois de
0,8 rien sans rien le rien dire et puis
c'est ce qui c'est ça c'est foutu le
bien disent ils c'est ça le pire de tout
ça c'est super je ne sais pas de papiers
on avait un papier mais encore le cas tu
peux rien qui rend ses poteaux rien qui
sort ouais 4,4 d'aucune information qui
rentre presque rien à raconter rien à
raconter une histoire à raconter
c'est une fête paniquer pete est
justement à l'an passé on est encore à
cette parenthèse de l'an passé note
s'apprêter montrer atv maintenant les
moments où est ce qu on les briques dans
mon avait des break down parce qu'on en
avait tout la gagne c'est tout le monde
le genre moi j'ai un souvenir précis de
moi qui pleurent qui est en sanglots
pour qu'une raison d'un litige en sang
des chemins avec les ans mais cette
année s'est montré on les voit un petit
peu plus on voit un petit peu le monde
qui sont convaincus
ça fait sept semaines calissons s'est vu
dix minutes dans semaine je capote les
tuer puis
mais c'est ce que c'est ça qui est le
plus difficile vraiment assez sûr besbes
lorsqu'il années passent aussi avait
aussi le guide jean de comment on fait
la transition entre ce que c'était avant
puisque c'est en train de devenir
je pense que cette année puis moi c'est
ce que j'aime en tout cas je prêche pour
ma paroisse est vraiment de façon très
sincère est ce que j'aime c'est que je
pense qu'il ya plus de respect aussi
envers ce que le public est capable en
savoie
je pense que de voir une cette semaine
bio en prenant part après l'amitié de
voir une marilyn qui fait littéralement
une crise d'anxiété pour nous à rodez
plus après c'est d'être capable de
nommer cette affaire l'une de parler du
soutien psychologique des candidats puis
de démontrer aux gens que c'est les gens
qui vous regardent et vivre la cdc des
vrais humains ça se peut que ça vous
arrive à vous aussi
just moi je trouve que cette porte là
cette brèche le nôtre est d'ouvrir non
seulement d'ouvrir la réalité dans la
télé réalité la vérité non la télé moi
je trouve ça je trouve ça très cool que
ce soit fait parce que j'aime ça
démontre que c'est pas beau c'est parce
qu'elles montrent peut penser qu'on se
faisait écrire souvent ému le total en
voyageant procopio les s'est pas
vraiment c'est quoi tu penses que tu
veux du monde vulnérable qui clairement
ça aux portes si tu peux te poser la
question de la première fois j'ai camors
et les folles mais quand tout le monde
croit les karaokés le sait peut-être pas
juste elle qui fut aussi tu peux le
ramener à ta propre vie
quant à des situations des épisodes de
par exemple dépressif ou d'anxiété
souvent tu vas faire et tout va bien
dans ma vie
suis pas capable de sortir c'est un
exemple parfait parce que des gens qui
vivent techniquement la rai life dans
des nouvelles maisons en grève qui sont
toutes dépenses payées peut payer même
et toutes dépenses payées la boxe sont
organisés ils ont rien à réfléchir ou à
peu près pis panique quand même on peut
l'appliquer très facilement tu as vite
ben oui mais ça tu as beau être riche
pour une bonne job avoir un bon tome
avant les meilleurs amis ça se peut
aussi que tu vives des épisodes
dépressifs
après ce schéma où on était je sais pas
mais je t'écoute parole est vraiment une
maîtrise la parole non mais c'est vrai
non pas vraiment non mais peut-être une
maîtrise puis je pense que c'est député
jeunes tout intérêt pour la
communication
ouais c'est ma job métissé ma job je
pense que j'ai l'obsession 6 2
la parole exact tu faisais pas des
concours oratoire alors je faisais mais
ça me sert en fait c'est comme ça que
toute ma vie a pris la tangente que le
prix qu'elle est aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs que quand j'avais 12 ans le
gibus pour mr démons avec ce métier
quand j'avais 12 ans je sens qu'on vous
un concours oratoire magie du québec
ckoi qu'on peut attaquer ce que foutent
face c'était ça s'appelait l'art de
s'exprimer je me suis donné une
thématique fallait écrire un texte là
dessus bien que le livre est devant
public qu'on était jugée sûre je ne sais
trop quoi le nôtre notre élocution
écriture la peau garnier mais avec un
animateur de radio à ce moment là qu'ils
étaient dans jury canada michel à
marcheprime et indigné on dirait qu il
ne peut-être antoine graines de quelque
chose qui pourrait devenir un quelconque
outils des médias journalistes et
chroniqueurs à québec
tout ce qu'on a salute france lesquels
cinq france c'est quand tu sors d quand
on sort d quand tu sors des échangeurs
des ponts lavigerie
moi j'habite être derrière le 5 super
boulevard lori saint thomas d'aquin
saint thomas d'aquin
c'est comme jeter 10 90 ans à moi c'est
comme je veux dire en termes socio
économique mais ça reste le parent
pauvre des paroisses parce qu'il n'y
avait pas d' équipes de soccer qui
s'appelait saint thomas d'aquin quand
j'étais petit petit puis quand je vois
qu'on les parois aussi avec ceinture sur
saint benoît
quand je veux qu'on dise il rit ans je
conseille jean baptiste mais thomas
d'aquino le hémois jetant dans les
scouts de saint-amand de chiffrer le
mytho les numéros promis fait approcher
par semaine massa puis au départ c'est
quelque chose de flou la radio me parle
toujours écouter la radio
tous les matins on se lever à 6 heures
c'était radio can je vais leur maison
jusqu'à ce qu'on quitte mais pour moi
c'est mon rapport à la radio à 7 ans
l'oeil était à cette époque là il était
vraiment différent ça veut dire que pour
moi c'était c'était intangible j'avais
même pas qu'il existait quelque chose
derrière l'objet qui me projetais du son
avec de me faire dire
aimerais-tu souvenez revisitée du sud ça
m'intéresse est même pas tant que ça
quand j'arrive au secondaire c'est en
sixième en est arrivé ce concours
oratoire même cochard aux seconds ag
commune l'épiphanie de exprès juste
aller voir de quoi ça al'air parentale
et s'ils sont malades rochebelle
transparaît dans le fond c'est qu'il
était te tais pas l'école l'éducation
alors ça c'est quelque chose que nous
faisons en a quelques-uns à l'égo de ça
car on prend en parler a parlé longtemps
longtemps les saluts d'aller visiter
cette station de radio l'oeil ma
chronique punch et comme l'outil ku
enfants à cette époque lettres et a10
entre promus et si comme la relève ku
qui quand est arrivé le 11 septembre
j'aurai comme proposé d'aller faire une
chronique qui ont dit qu'ils étaient sur
la perspective des jeunes par rapport à
ce qui s'était passé à partir de ce
moment là je pense que ça pour un enfant
de 12 ans tu penses à cette démarche
j'aimerais te dire que je t'aime je
pense que si je t'ai surtout naïf pour
être bien honnête
est-ce que la ligne est mince en
patrouille 9
euh non ça me plaît mais je pense qu'à
un certain âge par exemple si une
question de maturité je pense car si tu
es à l'âge adulte et naïve ténacité
watteuw besoin de quelqu'un de normal le
plus naïf même si ça m'a servi c'est
quand même qui est une priorité mon com
garder dans leur sillon même fait faire
des chroniques l'été puis tous à sa main
petits contre télé seychal en atm agent
qui a re en a 3 1 pis si ce n'est que je
pense qu'ils estiment tantôt on parlait
du muscle qui intellectuels qui se perd
quand tu passes 4 mois rien faire je
pense que l'un vers ce qui t'arrive et
pour moitié le muscle la communication
j'ai commencé à travailler vraiment
jeunes l'apprécient ya vraiment évolué
c'est à dire que pi le cheval le médium
aussi a évolué taser qui était à
l'époque pour moi fab et comme c'était
parler comme un radio canadien je les
fait très très longtemps tu essaies de
me conformer très très longtemps le
titre dans mon adolescence je me suis un
jean-pierre un mandat ni un prof à qui
je pense à qui je dois probablement la
version de la carrière que j'ai
aujourd'hui
kim a pris dans son bureau bernard
poirier qui m'a dit
c'est ce que tu es dans la vie c'est
assez
pas besoin de jouer à être quelque chose
de plus et a besoin de jouer à être un
communicateur de besoin de jouer à être
un animateur de radio besoin de jouer et
être un journaliste ce qui limitait
d'aider des figures qu'ils imaginent que
oui oui je me suis jamais réentendu à
cette époque le lundi je me suis jamais
réécouter mais je me souviens que ma
conception des affaires était très très
rigide
je pense que c'est important d'avoir un
certain standard m'apprécier aussi
l'importance d'être compris dans le
vecteur des émotions dans ton comme le
ciment fait dira si tu parle vite
puis au départ fermeture à qui je vais
essayer de parler moins vite je vais
essayer de bien manger si je disais à
quelqu'un est pour verser ces mondes
ebit conversationnel de vie inhumaines
puis on comprend très bien le message
peu trop vite qu'on comprend mal ce que
je pense que défoncé sera servi à ce
qu'on dit être en tout si on veut
toujours standardisés puis mettre les
affaires dans des bois puis normaliser
les choses pour mon ami je pense qu'il
faut être capable de comprendre c'est
quoi les bases puis pourquoi les gens
nous demandent de correspond à ses
standards puis sa broche ou nous ça nous
conte la radio canada c'est peut-être
moins vrai aujourd'hui mais demain est
vraiment c'est justement cette manière
de parler l'espèce de musique de ton de
voix qui comme si mme rackettaient que
différentes personnes mais c'est ce même
débit de ces mêmes notes libre encore
plus ou nouvelle peut-être moi j'ai
jamais posé la question moi j'ai des
amis qui travaillait aux nouvelles qu'on
ait des baux emploi mais qui me parle
pas dans la vie comme il parle à la télé
sont formés pour avoir cette espèce de
débile et ou sorties nature j'imagine
que oui mais je parle au directeur de
l'information probablement qu'ils
seraient capables de t'expliquer
pourquoi ça existe moi où j'ai toujours
eu un problème c'est justement tu y es à
la radio nous quand on est arrivé avec
le show qu'on a fait l'année passée la
retirer mais cette année avec fait du
bruit c'est premièrement nous c'est
clair que on a les posts vous voyez
vingtaine début trentaine tech on se
tutoie on utilise des anglicismes puis
on à paula
on a volonté encore une fois d'avoir de
trouver le moins exacts puis d'avoir la
façon de communiquer la plus limpide
possible bon s'impose pas de règles
comme le dit notre réalisatrice qui
n'existe pas mais ça ça brasse les
affaires beaucoup mais oui les auteurs
ainsi que dans les corridors des gens
peu plus vieux des gens qui sont des
expressions non non non dans l'atome se
demande ce qu'on fait en ondes métille
aucun changement de son look sites
opérés en étant consensuel fois que je
le vis bout j'ai jamais compris pourquoi
la semaine prochaine et vous vois moi je
pense que ça sert le le rythme
humoristique panne chez avec un vous ça
s'est tellement la rupture de ton avec
tout le reste de l'émission que je pense
que c'est peut-être cela joke 50 jpy
ramasse jean sébastien goulet mais qu'il
fonce vous voyez je te respecte mais je
ne voyais pas c'est vrai que c'est cool
puis j'avais écouté pardon j'avais
écouté qu'un l'art de talent et à la
chaire est encore jeune puis amené ne
dit pas besoin mais vous voyez le tout
le monde puis au départ mais je suis
d'accord chalet la semaine passée où il
ya deux semaines c'est exactement ce que
je me disais si j'ai eu mon réflexe
surtout que c'est des gens qui connaît
dans la vie si je sors jean-sébastien
jean-philippe on se croise jamais je
veux dire vous à jean-philippe ou jamais
de réduire voire jean-sébastien le tard
yvan nom de soudainement il faut que tu
vois comme un mécanisme avec moi je
pense vraiment qu'ils font pas bien
est-ce que avec l arrivée de tous les
nouveaux médias est ce que tu penses que
c'est mais diop traditionnels
doivent s'ajuster justement en laissant
parler du monde pas de façon
traditionnelle si on veut parler je
parle pas nécessairement juste du
langage les invitant la façon de les
communiquer dans la structure c'est sûr
à 100 pour un
assez compliqué parce qu'ils étaient pas
mettre les pieds dans les plats non plus
on entend des choses que je peux pas
dire mais
c'est sûr que l'idée
de la convergence entre les médias
traditionnels puis le médiocre qu'on
appelle numérique le ça va finir un jour
ce terme leurs actes comme compliquée à
instaurer dans des institutions je pense
que ça vient beaucoup de la lourdeur des
structures qui sont là des enveloppes
budgétaires qui existent au 6 mai
je suis
sauf que souvent qu'il est ne s'en fait
pas de casque pour le choix s'est jamais
rien que
si je le pensais pas je le pense ce que
je pense c'est que ya un problème entre
l'idée par exemple pour nous de faire un
show en direct le vendredi soir que ce
soit le considérer comme le produit
premier que tout ce qui se passe sur le
numérique par la suite soit considérée
comme la deuxième que la troisième place
4e fenêtre moi je pense qu'il faudrait
qu'on traite ses affaires le comme un
seul produit
tu es le jeu pour entrer dans les
enfants trop technique de podcasts mais
la plupart des gens connaissent des
américains noirs commun des podcasts les
plus populaires au monde
ça commençait à la radio chicago c'est
encore un show de radio mais les gens là
la popularité de l us le mangez jamais
évidemment écouter show en direct à
chicago et moi fait du bruit j'ai les
coudes dans mon téléphone c'est ça c'est
ça mon point mais c'est juste que
beaucoup d'énergie émise autour de
stratégies traditionnelles alors que je
me dis puis c'est un combo depuis c'est
pour ça que j'ai dit c'est la beauté de
travailler pour les services publics
saucisson d'âne cède c'est ça c'est une
grosse structure une grosse machine qui
donne d'énormes ressources marques
associées a effectué un pivot
on se demande quand même sympa de
récréation pense aussi que ça va être
exactement je la prenne mais je me dis
qu'ils entrent aujourd'hui puis le
moment où il ya quelqu'un qui veut dire
oh c'est dans le temps où vous faisiez
ouais je vais opérer le plus de
changements possibles si je vais je
faire partie de ce changement mais
parlons-en de fait du bruit moi je
trouve que ce ne sont que j'adore en
fait merci puis je trouve ça vraiment
bon pis tian que j'écoute ses missions
le je me sens interpellé cinq titres que
tu me parles
chaque vous me parlez puis ça fait du
bien c'est parce que c'est quelque chose
tu es à 27 ans dresser comme l'ange
ou que les gens d'un auteur je commence
à être plus visible c'est vrai si
quelqu'un quand j'allais voir jay du
temple en show j'ai eu la même à face
que ça saigne maurice qui parlent à ma
génération
quand j'écoute fait du bruit si ceci dit
l'animateur s'est dit les personnes des
radios qui parlent à ma génération big
s'adresse à tout le monde mais piégeux
mais ça je me sens interpellé puis ce
qui fait que c'est seul but et nous ou
en notre nom notre nom mot clé si ce
n'est le central c'est créer du contenu
engageant
c'est le moins engageant revient sur
tous nos souvent dans nos conversations
parce qu'on se dit oui oui c'est un bon
sujet maintenant comment on engage les
gens envers ce sujet le le vecteur que
nous on trouve souvent c
partir d'un thème entre éléments
personnels c'est d'un sujet d'après ce
ouvrir la sphère vers une réflexion plus
universel qui veulent nous appartenait
en mai qui peut par exemple parler ou
par la bh ou qu'importe
après ça ce qui est compliqué je pense
dans l'idée de la génération dont tu
parles
c'est quand c'est beaucoup parlé de
l'idée
ce fait qu'en fait la radio pour les
jeunes
ce sam
ça m'insulte littéralement mais parce
que tu m'as dit l'on s'entend mais ça
m'insulte de me faire dire ça d'abord
souvent par des gens qui nous écoutent
pas eux qui se base sur la forme plus
que sur le fond
parce que c'est pas vrai
travail pop parce que dire quand on fait
de la radio pour les jeunes c'est comme
de dire qu'on tourne les coins ronds
qu'on a pas une volonté de parler au
large public qu'on met pas les énergies
nécessaires pour raconter des histoires
qui sont porteuses pour tout le monde
alors que je pense que s'il ya une
équipe dans toute cette tour l'opsis
sans rien enlever à tout le monde qui
travaille à radio can si une équipe qui
se posent des questions sur comment
rejoindre les gens attelage cb news
quand on est assis les lundis matins
pendant deux à trois heures pour faire
un show d'une heure le vendredi
constituent des sujets puis on s'obstine
dont on se demande comment votre artiste
de cette affaire le mouvement comme on
peut créer du contenu engageant long du
monde comme on veut créer une
conversation qui vont il va parler aux
gens
puis pendant toute la semaine on trouve
des virgules on twitte des femmes dans
nos écouteurs quand on quand on est en
train de faire du montage on change des
mots tu te comprends vous raconter des
estives de bonnes histoires qui souvent
on est réduit à un bon show johnny parle
moi des histoires par mody contenu par
mois de ce que ça te fait vivre parce
que je sais que ça fait vivre des choses
ou non leur soient là on est soit les
messages moi la beauté de ces maisons
aux trousses et que
non seulement on va apprendre les sujets
mon lévis et piment cinéma ont créé
vivre des émotions c'est sûr je trouve
c'est vraiment la force puis cpo torah
c'est vraiment de je pense à l'épisode
sur le déracinement they were qu' il ya
un segment sur les gens qui ont été
expropriés de l'art sarlat leurs
souffrances leurs peines et pas juste
une statistique de qui on sait que tant
de personnes ont été expropriés c'est
vraiment justement puis sa fille que tu
vaux comprendre une problématique sous
un autre niveau un autre sponsor du fait
divers une sorte de l'actualité chaude
aussi c'est la beauté de ce qu'on peut
faire avec fait du bruit c'est qu'on ne
la possibilité souvent dans un court
laps de temps mais on a quand même la
possibilité de prendre du recul sur les
affaires et qui quand on est en réunion
c'est certain moment quand même fort ou
gabita river bien dit
exactement ce qu'elle a raconté
d'enseignement le bref ce qui est arrivé
c'est sûr est rachid pour les gens qui
connaissaient pas l'histoire sera celle
à montréal il y avait un bloc qui
étaient pas des logements sociaux mais
j'étais dix ont habité par des gens qui
étaient à plus faibles revenus tirés des
ménages à plus faible revenu
pis le propriétaire au laissez le
bâtiment 7 décrépir jusqu'à ce qu'ils
puissent et vinci en fait évacuer les
locataires pour pouvoir revendre
l'immeuble probablement le transformer
bien faire des condos on sait pourquoi
bref cette histoire les temps c'est un
fait divers c'est et 30 personnes ont
été évacuées c'est une problématique
ça existe dans le sacco news de 24
heures dati sauf que gabelle qui fait
partie du show si dans son quartier et
qu'elle disait si tu es mon paysage
passer tous les jours je viens du monde
fume des clopes jaser tripes et à être
heureux pidjot lendemain ça existe un
oui on s'est techniquement ce qui s'est
passé mais que s'est il réellement passé
que sont devenus ces gens là qu'est ce
qu'ils vivent nous autres c'est ce qu'on
fait ouais ça confie c'est là qu'on
réalise gab est arrivé avec sa pipe il
dit moi je connais un gars dont la job
c'est de s'arranger pour que le monde
[Musique]
chrysler qu un de leurs appartements
pour que les gestionnaires de ces
immeubles ont en fait les propriétaires
de ces immeubles
puissent les rénover lui dis c'est pas
de l'embourgeoisement mettez les
embourgeoisé pilule ou iep de façon plus
lucrative pour le propriétaire des clans
fait acquis une double histoire là
dedans ça va raconter c'est peu
aujourd'hui trente personnes ont été
évacuées voici les statistiques de
logements sociaux à montréal on sent
votre acompte et sait c'est qu'ils les
humains qui sont victimes ou qui vivent
cette situation le et on on le fait sans
jugement c'était ça l'objectif c'est que
quand on est allé avec le gag le
gestionnaire dit lui même qui s'appelle
nicolas jpy tout ce qu'on a dit s'y
posent des questions - pas de narration
pas de jugements n'ont pas de musique
non plus qui nous qui sous-entend ce
qu'on est en train de réfléchir d'un
point de vue éditorial dans vos laisser
les gens faire confiance à
l'intelligence du monde quand ils vont
écouter le contenu pour moi 6,6 ses
réflexions aux leurres que je voudrais
que les gens qui qui parlent de notre
show comprennent ce que j'ai
l'impression de comprendre ce que j'ai
pas l'impression que des gens des fois
qu'ils nous regardent qui font comme au
label brandon se pose comme le
témoignage de ce gala j'écoutais ça que
ma blonde tu te mentir des choses qui
font sur six sur six multi avec un
naturel puis une désinvolture je sais
pas trop si c'est pas normal
si son travail pour lui ce travail comme
un autre puits qui a exproprié déjà en
échange d'un paquet de cigarettes comme
voyons dans thé chauffe qui a moral
c'est ça faire c'est ce puits en même
temps jeudi
le fait qu'il ait qu il raconte sans que
ce soit édité sent qu'il ya et non plus
le l'agenda de faire pareil pour ce gala
pour un camp se fait que tu comprends sa
réalité legault c'est que la réalité
c'est que ces points quand ces seules
affaires sexy par rapport à moi par
rapport à mes valeurs je trouve ça
difficile à digérer mais dans les faits
le ghost un self made men que vu une
opportunité que c'est une opportunité
qui accomplit sa job de façon et
correct quotidiennement qui obtient des
résultats
après ça si ces résultats est ce que ces
résultats-là me convienne ou pop à moi
personnellement
ouais je sais pas à moi de le dire à la
radio publique
exact mais la business que la morale
c'est sa face à fond c'est ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'on demanderait sopi moi c'est
ce que je veux c'est clairement une
écoute ce segment à noter que tekken 5
ta blonde this fast
et le soin et le sale ou et moi je
comprends pauvres et pourquoi ce goal 1
et dans cette démarche le ce que ce que
tu décris de ton la façon de tester ou
que vous essayez de livrer les histoires
ça me fait vraiment beaucoup pensé mon
mon sujet de maîtrise sur le nouveau
journalisme aux états unis années 60 le
pis ce que tu décris la cccc d'aller au
delà du qui quoi où comment sais tu fais
du verre de rentrée depuis de décrire
les nuances des personnages inclus dans
ces eaux là
puis j'ai travaillé sur intéresse
thomson est ce qu'il fallait dans les
airs jazz qui tu lis son livre saint
just
pis tu comprends les les membres des
hells d'agir comme ils agissent selon
leur position
c'est ultra nuancé pour toi ça devient
des personnages je comprends mieux que
par exemple l'article d'un journaux lui
disent ouverts c'est l'article d'un
journal qui dit aller à saint john ont
mis le feu à telle place puis ont
saccagé tal afar où il y à t'il cendre
grand exact mais quand lui rampe à
l'intérieur explique de l'intérieur puis
lui il aimait son jugement par le choix
de ce qui montre par exemple qui est
sauf qu'il reste quand même noter que tu
vois tu vois ça tu puis tu t'y rendre
beaucoup plus dans l'histoire du fait
divers puis ce que tu décris la 6e puis
je trouve ça je trouve c'est vraiment
une bonne façon moi ça m'intéresse
beaucoup plus que le journalisme
traditionnel c'est ce que je pense aussi
une question jour la question de
contexte mais pour balancer sur ce
qu'ils étudient le jeu mon sac labeaume
est en train de lire un recueil des
sites x abel kingue nonfiction mois puis
danse dans ce recueil je pense que c'est
dans la préface que à glace et hors
glace cannabis american life com était
le curateur ses parents français le
curateur de ce livre là je pense que
c'est lui qui écrit ça dans sa préface
widi la constante des bon roi de la
non-fiction des gens qui font donc par
exemple journalisme - ou ce genre de
truc là c'est un la perspective qu'ils
adobe et de leur refus de jugement des
individus de qui raconte son mac
toujours avant leur regard de leur
analyse la situation mais jamais leur
jugement sur l'humain du mois le pis
pour ceux qui pour en revenir à ce qu'on
dit en double finir là-dessus t
c'est ce que gm mais de cette double
histoire qu'on a raconté par rapport à
l'évacuation des
qui s'envolent y est le mode coop par
rapport à 7,7 gestion immobilière le
sait y a personne qui est à les juger
neil pauvre monde qui ont été évincés
évacués de leur immeuble ni le mauvais
ni le méchant qui évince des gens pour
rénover les appartements parce que la
vie est pour demain
les gens qui voient la vie de façon
manichéenne qui font c'est tout noir ou
tout blanc
moi personnellement j'en veux pas dans
mon entourage mes fils et encore moins
dans mon équipe de radio
ouais
on se méfie c'est parce que la vie ces
postes n'est jamais ce jour non des
grippes i qui quand qu'on se parle on se
rend compte que beaucoup plus de choses
qui nous unissent quelque chose qui nous
sépare tpiy on aime s'identifier à digue
à des groupes ou à des positions
mais quand qu'on se parle vraiment on se
rend compte que c'est pas aussi ferme
sipa aussi des clans qu'on le pense ça
ramène soit nettement en piste pour
faire un mauvais ligne ça ramène
cette conversation leur ramène le sujet
à au jugement que les gens portent quand
ils font pourquoi tanner mode et plus
c'est une autre phase astuces ben oui
j'en ai surtout plus entendu parler que
je l'aï ressenti probablement dans un
gros passé sélect de gens qui sait l'un
et l'autre c'est à dire que c'est du
monde qui va te dire mais tu es
tellement un garçon brillant et du coup
pourquoi tu vas faire ouais c'est ça
mais c'est parce que la vie dans ma
petite cause de niches à gauche plus à
racheter dans la petite coche d'une
classe de neige à gauche puis l'inversé
est aussi vrai c'est pas parce que tu es
la télévision du contenu populaire que
tu peux pas faire du contenu qu'ils
soient un petit peu plus jadis sensible
entre que je vais utiliser le mot
raffiné le sentier pas de raffinement
dans ce que l'autre fait mais oui on
peut dire ça finit montre que travailler
cette chose n'existe pas on peut
s'autoriser à un multiple tant qu'on est
cohérent dans la façon dont on fait les
choses plus ce que je trouve importantes
point plusieurs choses qui on est tous
plusieurs choses oui c'est moi ce
commentaire le jeu l'a entendu pas parce
que j'ai animée au 205 mais parce que
j'ai fait ou non j'ai entendu cela
beaucoup venant de d'un champ
et pratique élitiste en guillemets même
si je n'aime pas ce mot le écrire
pourquoi pourquoi te fais ça tu essaies
d'en beys mainstream c'est demain
vide alors qu'au final c'est une
expérience probablement l'expérience la
plus enrichissante que j'ai vécu toute
ma vie tu puisses je dois garder avec
moi après je regarde avec moi pour
écrire je regardais mois pour vivre
après évidemment que tout est nuancé
tout est gris puis c'est pas parce que
j'ai fait une émission comme ce que tout
le travail intellectuel que j'ai fait
dans ma vie à vingt vaut plus rien
validé c est l idée
l'idée c'est aussi de ré approprier
ce que tu es ne pas être défini par
expérience le sait plus seulement j'ai
l'impression que les gens veulent
attribuer aux gens qui font des shows
comme rodez c'est que c'est comme si la
seule chose qui les définit à partir du
moment où il met le pied dans une maison
à bas liés au portugal à whistler en
grèce ou à blainville ce qu'il devienne
pour le reste de leur vie des candidats
ou des bio quand même je pense une
espèce de de travail de déficit l'aja
faire pour arrêter d'exister dans tête
du monde dans la perception des gens
comme étant secondes 8/10 que les choses
parce que la passion des gens c'est une
information qui ont sur toi tu es si la
seule qui m'est en mettant comprendre
justement le jeu d'occupation d'opci
mettons telle personne et est tout le
temps en colère information marie line
s'ils étaient dans la maison mais se
remettra jamais inspecté les spectateurs
va voir l'apeline d'information de toi
mais tu veux cannes est le plus possible
qu'ils se rendent pour qu'ils voient ici
c'est qui la personne c'est qu'on n'est
pas juste et images ainsi que j'aimerais
ce qui est dur au 6 bis c'est ce que je
ressentais pour les gens comme toi ou
des gentils thani qui ont fait au 10
août et à dans mon coeur je croise
encore qu'ils servent quand même seul à
dire là dessus c'est l'idée que
si toi tu passe à autre chose les gens
vont quand même dans une certaine
proportion de ramener à cette affaire
moi c'est ça l'impression que j'ai qui
doit être dure pour vous aussi
de vous faire le choix que vous êtes
passé à une autre étape de votre vie que
les gens soient encore en train de faire
a été la fois la semaine 8 août lt la
noire vous donnons à vie j'ai envie de
poser une question comment vous deal
avec ce je pense que dans notre cas nous
on ne reçoit pratiquement plus aucune
aucun commentaire daudet aucune
rétroaction 1 n'ont pratiquement plus
parce que je pense qu'on a réussi à
filtrer quand même le monde qui nous
suivaient par rapport à d'autres enjeux
comme le véganisme par exemple pousser
maintenant l'entraînement pour moi ou le
féminisme pour gc c'est plus facile pour
nous parce qu'on a on est devenu quelque
chose d'autre ben c'est pas un travail
que s'est fait facilement
c'est ça a été long le tribut au début
c'est qu'on aurait pu paniquer quand les
chiffres diminuent
qu'est ce que je fais est ce que je
devrais faire comme par exemple en ce
moment que karine fait ce que je devrais
essayer de le commenter aude et puis
d'essayer de m'afficher avec des
nouveaux candidats pré sident de revenir
un peu au 1a surface de cette vague là
si on veut mais je pense qu'il nous on
n'en veut laisser passer cette vague là
qu'on aurait embarqué sa prochaine
d'après puis sur une autre on le vit
bien mais ça s'est pas fait facilement
il a prêté une transition qui a été
facile puis je peux comprendre que pour
certains surtout maintenant avant quand
je mens des eaux d et je pourrai pas de
nommer personne à part ceux qui ont
gagné des années à 26 ans son île son
pull et jade goody les autres mais ce
qui marche bien mais ouais c'est ça puis
l on entend même plus par les hindous
des appareils mais c'est donc en fait y
en a pas beaucoup qui ont réussi à faire
ça y est c'est 1,6 à drac est difficile
mais en même temps
il ya beaucoup de monde qui écoutent
d'occupation de 1 mais il ya encore plus
de monde qu'ils écoutent pas s'est il
encore vraiment c'est de ce monde qui
l'écoutent pas qu'ils entendent même pas
parler là moi je me suis désabonné à la
page d'occupation double sur facebook
puis mon facebook
j'en entends plus parler alors que quand
j'étais abonné c'est juste ce qu'avait
simon fait ici et là je me suis
désabonné j'entends juste pas parlé puis
je me dis à beaucoup de monde qui ont
suivi l'émission mais il y en a encore
vraiment plus qu'ils n'ont pas suivi
puis ces gens là ils commencent à nous
suivre puis je me dis pour ces gens là
je serai pas mais beaucoup le monde qui
nous écrivent en disant je n'écoute pas
la télé chez nous je vous ai découvert
pour votre livre de recherche de
découverte et à la fin et je te suis
pour telle chose et du monde qui m'écrit
pour l'entraînement je trouve ça cool la
difficulté c'est de réussir à faire
quelque chose qui
plus gros en guillemets de chaos des
thèmes en éthique et en touche par les
deux formations les gens sont au courant
s'est rendu jusqu'à ce que vous faisiez
autre chose que vous aviez un livre de
recettes et c'est des gens qui jaillit
que théo di palma et ne parlant autant
même s'ils n'ont plus que six qui vont
co scoop qui voyez votre livre monde
pense au costco qui moi m'a face au
kiosque au fait que vous avez réussi
comme un terme auraient réussi à
surpasser au d'étiquettes un brin ne
nous pas encore fait à 100%
vous savez même pas un certain temps
déjà mais tout ça c'était le garantit à
tout les par une ligne droite par et oui
ouais dans ce sens qui te fini tu
entends ton programme à l'uqam celui des
appels pu te vois j'ai commencé à
travailler ça a été quand même ici mais
je dirais jamais simple parce que c'est
toujours plus compliqué qu'on pense ce
sera compliqué quand on a un objectif
c'est beau c'est pas moi je tiens
vraiment à part être connue je peux pas
à être une grande vedette
ce que je veux c'est juste avant les
opportunités n'en fait plus ça va aller
plus je vais avoir des opportunités qui
correspond de façon plus précise âme
mais réel intérêt une réelle envie tu
sembles aimé mettre les autres mettent
le spotlight sur les autres a fait la
musique émergente pitt fait beaucoup
pour pour la propager
je les dis tantôt mais moi je vois mon
travail comme celui d'un conduit -
prochain conduit entre une forme de
contenus qu'il ment et quand on parle
par exemple du podcast de music show
avec mon ami alexis dionne unis des
entrevues confins union 6e c'est
vraiment juste d'être le conduit
éditoriale entre il ya un million de
nouveaux artistes
un million nouvelle toune qui sortent
chaque jour chaque semaine ils exagèrent
presque pas c'est quoi que tu es ligne
que nous on fait comme on peut vous
l'amenez qu'après ça vous en ferez bien
ce que vous voulez moi je pense que le
petit contexte qu'on donne au tour la
façon dont tout le package puis la
passion qu'on y met mais ça va permettre
à des gens de découvrir des nouveaux
trucs téchnologie pas de responsabilité
tant que tout part d'une passion mais je
pense que tout pas vraiment de la vider
de conect que les gens connectent entre
eux puis que les gens connecte avec les
sujets probablement que les sujets quels
qu'ils soient va devenir le leader du
monde à qui on pas que ce soit 1000
personnes sur un épisode d'union ou
trois cent mille quand on fait au
dimanche c'est pour samsung de santis
ton ex en tant qu'arrière spam house
avons toujours évolué ouah je crois pas
à ce temps que ça être son ex dans vie
sauf que c'est commun faire partir un
autre a coulé cas ces gens là je veux
dire oui bon vous avez raison donc je ne
suis pas arrivé à mon premier x mais
peut-être que mon premier qui n'existera
pas avant malheureusement c'est que je
disais non je me sens pas
particulièrement sur mon x mais je me
sens pas particulièrement déstabilisé
par rapport à la carrière que que je
mène c'est ce que j'ai toujours des
objectifs
qui sont plus loin que c'est pas
nécessairement de l'ambition c'est juste
des objectifs précis de contenu à
atteindre de gens atteints de façon de
faire les choses mais c'est quoi la
carrière de rêve ou bien les le contexte
de railleu pour toi et tu te vois
d'antan
je le sais pas mais moi je pense pas que
je vais faire ce métier l'ofs
c'est
au far from de tout le titre de sadran
dans l'animation devant des caméras
toute ma vie ni même très très longtemps
dans dix ans il ya des chances que je
fasse plus nécessairement là de télé et
j'aimerais ce rêve probablement faire
encore de la radio est géré aussi du
contenu audio thx et je pense que je
m'en rends compte en faisant fi du bruit
tiges et j'ai un lit notions techniques
pour le faire c'est pour faire la preuve
je pense que j'ai lu l'élu la structure
intellectuelle pour guider des gens dans
cette façon de raconter des histoires de
femmes storytelling en audio et
potentiellement que s'arrête sauter dans
une loge c'est chercher peau
j'ai aucune idée mais j'ai pas de rêves
particulier peut ainsi pas limpide une
direction
non666 je pense que si j'avais un rêve
ce serait peut-être
de sortir des frontières du québec mais
pas nécessairement en animation le
métier de dante dans le travail en tant
que team essex pour ce que je dis
peut-être que l'idée d'aller de
travailler sur de l'audio de travailler
sur des contenus musicaux pour des
entreprises ont un peu plus grosse
ailleurs dans le monde s'apprête quelque
chose qui va m'intéresser jusqu'à l'idée
de ces ceux d'annie heures
un gala des gémeaux braig prend la place
de james remplacé se prennent une
[Musique]
excellente maman finances rôle c'est sûr
que quand charvaux des plus en direct
lodges et si yavin une question des
sketches il va continuer à faire aux
détenus n'ont posé la question tu le
ferais tu il non je pense pas vraiment
mes amis de dire il ya un an aurait
demandé aux partis à rire fait que je me
rétracte et ce que j'ai peut-être que je
le ferais mais il ya potentiellement des
gens qui sont bien meilleurs pour faire
cette double voie parce que jean se
raconter à quel point il existait aussi
le pire
j'avais peur du bâclage ce n'est pas
juste positif c'est un bon choix le fait
connaître par un public qui l'aurait
jamais rencontrés autrement un pion
public gip en plus le sud c'est sûr que
tu quand tu penses que quand tu es
entouré de cantat meilleur ami c'est
catherine le vague par exemple qui
passait dans un dans un conduit quand
même assez précis pis vraiment bien
vraiment bien ficelé le testateur calais
fait les bons choix au bon moment
j'étais assez nerveux lac mois puis son
one woman show les autres quand tu vois
des purs acteurs du jeu des comédiens
mais comme il y en a qui font ses choix
l'homme qui réussissent à prayssas
vendre vous convient à combien rendu le
matin 250 billets au coût de billets
doit dire ah c'est peut-être ça le
chemin que je devra emprunter entre que
c'est le chemin pure en premier mais si
le chemin qui mène à rome
ouais je pense qu'il s'est demandé si ça
allait faire de lui un animateur et puis
un humoriste alors que simon pour moi
geste un humoriste qui anime tout le
résultat d'un shop ces salles sont
pleines ex un métier en même temps
est-ce que c'est nécessaire de définir
d'alerté jesse j'ai du temps dans sa
phase de l'humour qu'il fasse caler mode
et c'est déjà du temps oui oui il fait
son or c'est de l'humour puis oui
animaux des mais c'est un animateur sur
l'humoriste on s'en fout les autorités
je pense que ce qui est intéressant dans
ce que tu dis là
ce qui est du temps parce qu'avant de
faire occupation double réfléchi à cette
idée du stand commun avec les gens
perçoivent pour ce qu'il est ce qu'il
fait et moi c'est ce que je trouve ça je
trouve admirable thunder et oui j'y
réfléchis oui j'ai décidé de le prendre
moi je vais toujours me souvenir de sa
première intro sur le tapis rouge
postuliez weezy on n'était pas là
c'est vrai il dit bonsoir
suit l'humoriste jay du temple bienvenue
occupation blesse on le fasse je me
souviens candiac et le gars c'est
vraiment posé la question qui a voulu
dire à tout le monde
sachez que j'allais monde et méchés un
humoriste et se détruit ce fabuleux
ce qui est encore plus fabuleux sexta né
il ya même plus besoin de jouer legault
qui est drôle ou non dans le mettre en
place l'idée qu'il est humoriste est
venu banino seulement tout le monde le
trouve exceptionnel à l'animation daudet
les gens vont voir ces shows il y en a
pas de problème puisque c'est ça veut
dire si c'est être bien accompagné sait
faire des bons choix de carrière c'est
d'être très lucide
voilà ce que tu fais professionnels le
dit lui-même le y avait tellement pas
que les gens sachent pas qui est drôle
kif avait tout pour être d'autres hippie
clos maintenant mais le chemin aux
filles elles travaillent moins 6 dé la
série les deux sens établi dans la façon
que les jeunes perçoivent ils ne le bien
dit aussi de la première fois je le
faisais pour la job maintenant je le
fais pour les fans qui s'est séparé par
kate von qui va aussi que l'équipe
travaille autour de lui ce qui n'est pas
le cas je pense à l'époque le jeu peut
parler d équipe que je connais pas mais
à l'époque c'était le souder tel est le
thème était la limite était le texte
dans bush puis c'était un peu du pareil
au même et échangeables pendant une
couple d'années j'ai l'impression qu'il
y avait des contraintes plus clair du
tout l'impression que c'est à dire toi
sérieux pitié c'est clair c'était
vraiment différent sur ie des épisodes
d'avant des super d'élimination moins du
monde
mais en même temps est ce que tout ça
aurait pu arriver sans la présence de
jay sens à vos longues les deux
d'exister de cette façon le nom d'un
concept pas mal certain que non je pense
que de nos jours fallait qu'un deuxième
degré c'est exactement pareil que lui
mettant dans les petites côtes entre les
seins ni ride ce qui s'est passé je
pense que nécessaire on peut cette
deuxième degré dans sur les rotules
l'exact même le monde qui travaille l
année passée je pense à jill qui sont
sur ce site il dit la plupart du monde
qui sont ici plat parlait pas de tous
les candidats mais en six ans au
deuxième degré l'outil nous on était là
au deuxième degré mathier moins de 6 ans
je veux dire qu'un grand qu'on me
parlait maintenant à rodez on parlait
pas inscrits wade a bien précis c'est
pas parce que tu fais des choses au
deuxième degré tu les fais pas avec
exactement victime est restée douze
semaines dans cette aventure le sinon
c'était mieux pour la gare pour la gagne
mais c'est comme ça qu'ils sentent la
juger les émotions dit le véhicule soit
question patinage de disques ou
peut-être au-dessus des infos à l'avance
de tous les enfants en avant pourrait
avoir des infos en avance mais puis le
monde me trouve extraordinaire magasin
aussi d'une musique plus mais moi je
veux pas que les gens parlent de ce qui
se passe après la tournée où on est en
train de tourner parce que comme je
disais tantôt étant le conduit du
téléspectateur dit le représentant du
téléspectateur sur le plateau si moi je
sais qu'une telle pendu manche puis tu
vas voir tu es le twist plus que tu es
la femme fera faire un jeu peu
l'échappée je n'aime pas de la même
façon les mêmes questions si tu sais que
de toute façon
legault par exemple la semaine passée si
j'avais su que c'est une colle au cul
par terre j'aurais pas posé les mêmes
questions sur les dynamiques entre j'ai
volé le wifi mode par exemple si j'avais
su qu'ils étaient partis spontanément
j'aurais pas eu ce réflexe l'heure mais
là je les ai dit comme tantôt j'écoutais
l'épisode de ce soir j'ai aucune idée de
ce qui se passe dimanche à bath qui
étaient les nôtres boys andré débarque
la benauge sais rien je trouve ça
parfait je veux pas savoir mais je veux
pas savoir peu après c'est sûr que n'est
par exemple marine janka qui est
tellement
gourmand tout ce qui peut sans
d'occupation double ça arrive qu'elles
ont échappé nous deux je grimpe à oracle
hc qui va se passer tel ou tel tourisme
en général c'est dans votre préparation
ça requiert pas sur l'enfant
ben non parce que nous on commente le
showdown à 13 jours sur notre objectif
c'est qu'est-ce que ce qui s'est passé
ce soir les chroniques des collabos
qu'est-ce qu'on peut extrapoler pour
faire du contenu
si ça reste 20 minutes de show man qui
pensent qu'on se casse la tête mais on
se casse pas la tête
outre mesure pour essayer de le créer du
contenu qui existent pour de créer à
partir de contenus qui n'existe pas
encore ou d'essayer de laisser des
petits indices au monde qu'on sait qu'il
se passe quelque chose plus tard puis
moi j'ai une autre question est ce que
vous faites
imposer des lignes éditoriales comme
quoi pas comme exemples tels personnages
ont vu qu'ils passent pour la gestion
des salles ou non non si si une chose
qu'on se fait toujours dire c'est la
suivante c'est essayer le plus possible
puis moi ça s'applique pourtant moins
mais plus hauts collaborateurs et si le
plus possible de produire quelque chose
à propos d'un candidat que vous lui
diriez pas dans la face je pense que
c'est arrivé beaucoup cette année aussi
là n'est pas à city je pense y ait eu
des moments où ça honnêtement je
l'écoutais pas fonctionné parce que j'en
ai compris sexy et quelques dérapages
des moments où c'était peut-être un peu
plus de garanties que c'est pas tout le
monde sait pas tout saisi sur moi que le
monde meurent 10 amour exact fait que je
pense que c'est ça et si cela n'est pas
ce qui est arrivé je pense que cette
année ils essaient de faire
une espèce de coupure entre
comment ça c'est ce qui lui vaut que tu
ferais entre nous autour d'une table en
disant que la personne est un personnage
qui n'existe que dans la télé puis des
familles ces gens là aussi des fois sauf
que
il ya un autre pan de cette affaire le
capot rapports ou à l'idée de tuer
d'iraty d'en face ou quoi mais aussi une
idée de défonce le dirait mais il ya un
peu d'acharnement sur tel ou tel
personnage un but tout fait ce sont des
adultes
doivent s'approprier ce qu'ils disent
assumer ce qu'ils disent aussi assumer
les attitudes qui sont je comprends
qu'on est des êtres complexes je
comprends qu est ce qu on voit la télé
c'est pas tout ce qui existe de la
personne dans la vie mais s'est malgré
tout dit c'est des choses qu'on fait
honnêtement un manque de respect c'est
qu'ils se soient pas que tu montes pas
de respect 24 heures sur 24 dans ta vie
un manque de respect flagrant envers eux
j'essaie de frais trop précis mais tend
vers un genre où une personne en
particulier
qui a un port
pour que ce soit noté si nous on note
possible si nous on ne note pas chaque
fois que ça arrive on fait pas notre job
on a une responsabilité aussi de nommer
les affame des les boys qui nous
écoutent en ce moment faire ce genre
d'affaires on vous le dit ça se fait pas
dans la vie en 1018 ça ne devrait pas
exister on me met tant que m'étant con
quand qu'on enlève les dragons a dit
qu'on parle de michael pendant 35 ans
c'est on ne parlait plus haut par casse
avec les yeux au sipi
moi j'ai trouvé que occupation double
que l'émission ça paraissait qui a
endossé pas du tout ces propos lundi
comme salonu personnage puisse à lui
j'ai trouvé qu'ils aient à l'exposé
quelque chose qui fait en sorte qu'ils
aient une réflexion mais que la personne
qui écoute ses missions le zippo
j'aurais y est je vais agir comme luisy
le contrat des pâquis je trouverais
moi c'est ce que moi c'est ce que j'ai
senti si peut-être que c'est pas tout le
monde qui qu'il perçoit la même façon
parce que michael pour moi y'a plein
niveau as je pense que à la base la
façon dont ça a été présentée puisse
résister la bonne façon ce averti tu
traites paul des filles de kaunas mon
gars tu fais pas ça non car yves ponnau
ça arrive pas dans notre société au
québec nous ont fait part ce
particulière mais je les jetais fautes
sur la fin on dit c'était de la sphère
culturelle mais à qui suit vraiment la
culture black sawn affaires culturelles
j'ai parlé avec une amie française ce
qu'à me dis c'est pas nécessairement le
fait qu'on va utiliser ce terme là de
façon constante dans la vie mais ce que
dit par contre c'est dans la télé
réalité la culture de télé réalité
française est complètement différente de
la nôtre
sinon on essaie quand même la rapprocher
le plus possible de la vie tandis que là
bas si tu veux te démarquer faut que tu
sois ce genre de personnage controversé
parce qu'il y en a qui font leur
carrière là-dessus et non une
téléréalité puis une autre puis une
autre parce que ils deviennent un
personnage de télé réalité je pense que
mickaël des choses que mal comprises
quand il t'arrive et puis témoin judo
j'ai eu la chance de parler quand il est
venu au québec - petit rencontré le
guide son adn suspects sous le lit
ah ben c'est pas c'est mon hobby combien
non mais bref
bush critiquent pope corey que vous le
nautisme et tiges secret qu'il allait
sais pas si je trouve dans l'émission la
wii parce que ça existe
le problème c'est pas tout le temps
protéger les gens de main surtout pas
quand il signe pour aller dans une télé
réalité je pense la chose de base là mon
sens à moi et quand j'ai des exemples de
cette année des situations de fait c'est
pas nécessaire on aurait pu faire in out
médecins à corbeil ça existe mais un
pourquoi je te protégerai alors que tu
as un comportement problématique
puis deux si on montre paul comportement
problématique
il ya aucune personne qui va être
capable d'avoir une réflexion soit sur
ses propres agissements soient sur la
les agissements non tpr est victime
d'une tierce partie non prononcé jeudi
six 6 1 le 16 juin loin d'un messi 1 go
donne une claque saylan fille
faudrait le monde mais il faudrait
prendre des dispositions 2 faudra le
montrer
parce que y'a peut-être quelqu'un
quelque part qui regardent ce show-là
qui ferait et c'est vrai que c'est pas
normal par exemple que mon homme madone
claque ça y est le ressentent en avant
l'exemple extrême qui aurait peint
d'autres affaires à constitue quand je
parle le caillage plus bas c'est mettre
une claque saillol verbal c'est ce que
je faisais moi après ce penser au moment
auquel voulaient passer ça se fait peau
neuve des affaires comprends mais c'est
une bonne façon de deux morceaux
la batterie tient à matri
changement de batterie
on soit redonné un petit peu ouest du
total et boya semaine on n'en sait si
vous connaissez sensu une manche
suédois s'est quand même longtemps qui
roule sa bosse le chiffre de dire le
nombre d'années exactes si c'est
purement acoustique une montre que les
chaudières basse type non et en solo
mais pas purement acoustique et ya sept
ans selon la ceni était magnifique vidéo
au métropolis om telus désormais nous 28
pc rare mais c'est un choix si en fait
une guirlande mentaux comme tout le
parterre et debout piteux les sciages
assia sommes restés des sièges que des
sièges a si bien que des sièges c'était
magnifique extraordinaire chaud
toujours impressionné par des artistes
ils partent en tournée en solo non
[Musique]
capter les gens pendant une heure encore
une heure trente il ya un truc qui me
faisait rire c
le monde puis moi c'est la chose qui
m'agresse le plus le je vous le dis dans
ma vie dans les shows c'est le monde qui
tapent des mains
si comme toujours les mauvais temps on
va se dire les gens tapent jamais ces
bandes télé les enthousiastes ils ont
trop enthousiaste tard possible
on va te le dire le gagne il faut taper
sur la avec les senneurs
j'ai eu deux trois quarts peau à 1 2 3 4
mais tout le monde les foules en france
particulièrement le stepway sur gaza sur
des plateaux c'est pas dans des sous des
tonnes de rap c'est agaçant bref c'est
ça le fait que le monde devenant pas
enthousiaste yable ç'a commencé à taper
des mains chaque fois que quelqu'un
commence à taper des mains comme miettes
en solo i ralentissez
jusqu'à 6 le monde arrête de taper des
mains pire comment ces demandes à
neydens rappel et le groupe cmh et comme
à la troisième rangée avant le statut
légal à la première rangée
je sais pas pourquoi mais c'est comme
s'il voulait le narguer puis continuer à
taper des mains même si ralenti de mon
ami est venu le voir pire comme jodie
les épandages arrête de taper des mains
dans ses cartons dans son groupe jeudi
tg c'est pas d'être associé jusqu'à moi
je suis tout seul ici il le délai entre
toi qui tapent des mois ce qui vient
jusqu'à moi y at il trop long
moi ça me fait mal j'ai trouvé ça drôle
puis en fait survécu c'est une bonne
leçon aussi pour les gens en général la
plupart des gens le tapage l'an passé
c'est un choix j'étais allé voir jean
leloup tout seul au grand théâtre je
pense puis le monde qui réagissent trop
dans des shows comme ceux qui sont tes
des choses ainsi mais trouve herti cité
puis jean louis joue avec ses mélodies
pu changer les paroles pour tu es allé
chercher la poésie puis le du monde qui
agissent en innocent chômage d'avant
ghana vain pendant je joue là je joue de
la guitare le rapport le refrain à quoi
je juge de la guitare que tout le monde
a entendu sont ultra déprécie vraie
satire de dépression s'est dit plein et
gueye monté seul stage pour aller mais
il n'y a pas de bandes sur par sept au
grand théâtre à temps parce que face aux
mets devant qui sont sortis type qui ont
sorti le gros pierre bellemare à côté de
moi qui riait comme sur les teintes
chaudes martin matte
mais ça va tellement hérité ce hameau
des genres et toi et que de la musique
des toits mais comme deux à farah il ya
un côté se voient le verre à moitié vide
dit que les gens réagissent comme ça
parce qu'ils ont souvent peur du silence
par que la réaction que la tante de
l'artiste soit pas la réaction que le
public devrait lui donner mais aussi
l'autre côté si tu vois le verre à
moitié plein ou tu peux dire
l'art fait quelque chose de différent à
chaque centime il quelque chose chez
chacun c'est ce come back en juger la
personne qui tapent des mêmes dates que
c'est sa façon de dire et j'aime
vraiment ce que je chanterai ne vivent
ou si son débordement d'émotions que
danser mais parce que j'arrive quand
même si je peux quand même de respecter
petit point de vue de l'artiste
l'artiste dit c'est le fait que les gens
tapent des mains ça s'anime mon
spectacle ça nuit à faire passer mon
message parce que pas vouloir au monde
est enthousiaste commentent les deux
mais mettons dans lequel la madame qui
riait à côté de moins ce qui est clair
mike et comprenait pas la chanson s'il
ne peut pas rire en écoutant ce à moins
qu'ils passent complètement à côté de
l'ordre s'étaient pris cannabis légal
s'ils s'étaient pris cannabis légal
comme ça c'était vraiment quelqu'un
cannabis légal
le ghana vend par exemple j'ai
l'impression que la loi
quant à lui pas djezzy un gars qui monte
sur la scène
l'automne passé j'ai eu lieu dès grugger
qui vont aller attendait il le traîne
avec lui en faut de la scène
mon ami a fait un signe que quelqu'un
qui mon cher c'est une belle prise de
contrôle
ça démontre aussi la stature d'un
artistique
un jeune de 19 ans des coups quand ça
arrive c'est comme les foo fighters qui
font monter la guerre
ça pourrait être une merde le cuivre est
incroyable ce qui est bien c'est de voir
la réaction si des artistes prennent ce
risque le puits que ça fonctionne il ya
aussi une vidéo superbe plat de michael
bublé je sais que moi j'ai monté un je
m'en allais le stress d'un cessez-le-feu
ce moment lol c'est les soldes est vrai
moment de grâce
chanter vient chanter parfaite c'est une
impression de faire un bon giro puis le
tour juste la fraction de seconde où il
fait bon comment je me sortir de cette
issue au chili comme la commune pac a
retrouvé mon fils à mon fils tu chantes
lice marchande et du locle au logement
légal avec angie qui a fait monter les
faits mon propos n'est pas de la fille
qui qui il fait monter un gosse le style
qui dit qu'il gardera payer plus il ya
une autre fait remarquable et même fait
monter l'autre ferait l'affairé jean
ramel tous complets leur expliquer aux
gens c'est ça je voulais que six ans
l'icône et les paroles c'est ce que je
voulais mais mettons tous les papillons
là dessus très monter quelqu'un de ton
public pour chanter les paroles des
chansons
kiala et noir dans tes paroles de la
chanson petit local pour faire ça quand
tu vois ça y est merveilleux merveilleux
ce même ami ce même cnt
jamais à juger moi y'a aucun des menaces
mais pourquoi s'est inquiété quoi c'est
quoi le sport c'est quoi qui a fait
monter une fille sur la scène pour
carabine de ses chansons blanchou et
puis dans les paroles il dit le noir
depuis l ère ap la toune il est un peu
piégée concentre là dessus mais non il
le papier ou parce que la sphère le sic
si la fille connaît les paroles par
coeur va le voir venir exact piqué et
rappe sur scène devant je ne sais trop
combien de milliers de personnes la
toune avec le hand c'est dans sa vie de
tous les jours quant à la ramq en
dansant avec dumont nous capables de ça
veut dire qu'elle utilise le mot allah
pour justement pas walk par rapport à
l'utilisation de semoule avec moi je
suis d'accord avec toi qu'il ya un
sentiment de piège parce que le ls se
fait humilier devant une grande foule
alors qu'elles n'ont rien demandé quoi
qu'on pourrait questionner cette affaire
là parce qu'il a quand même accepté
d'aller sur la scène membres et ceux ci
kendrick l'espace est ce
yahia envoie pas le bon message avec
comme j'avoue qu'il ya comme un an comme
on dit en taule il y en ait dans les
nuances des greens mais comment il
réagit lui c'est que c'est quoi qui
s'est passé après mais dès qu'elle a
commencé le tournoi dit l'arrêté pile le
colis publiquement petite fée jeunesse
jeudi dans tout le monde s'est fait que
la fille et c'est en sortir ou court au
plus juste comme malaise à pile à y
avait peut-être une façon plus délicate
de le faire c'est pour mais on n'avait
pas de la sensibilité aussi les autres
on est ici au québec dispose situation
qu'on vit de façon constante comme si il
y en a un qui est aussi pour toutes ces
causes de non mais je ne quitte une
sensibilité qui est peut-être plus c'est
plus à fleur de peau là dessus la boue
noire c'est ce matin mais c'est instinct
j'avais pas entendu parler de cette
pression là mais c'est vrai que ça pose
la question parce que par si les paroles
mais non mais je comprends comment ce
constat aucune explication mais mais je
comprends aussi que lui aussi ces termes
le lait celui ci une question sur les
approprient en fait c'est toute la
question parce que l'élève
je pense que c'était des box pour moi
expo et il connaît dansant sous et des
gens qui vont toujours dire ouais mais
tu es
si le mot ni gros pour vous c'est un
coeur sword pourquoi vous l'utilisez
vous même en vous parlant entre vous et
la crise de la question de la
réappropriation pour moi et cellule le
débat il ya quand même des gens qui vont
continuer à s'obstiner la noire mais je
pense que la meilleure façon de se
justement tu y es il ya wynton marsalis
ccq saint tropez this de jazz et de nom
dans le fond c'est cinéma trompettiste
de jazz mais ils trient quand même très
pure et c'était quand même très
conservateur que de moi musicalement en
pis lui ce qu'il dit c'est clair pour
lui la musique hip hop ce noir
évidemment
pour lui la musique hip hop c'est la
plus grande
grand frein à l'émancipation des noix ou
les plus quelque chose qui fait plus des
dommages qui est bien à la cause ce sont
les pignons médecin je comprends qu'ils
je comprends que c'est quand même assez
de mettre beaucoup de choses dans une
valise c'est ce que la musique hip hop
ces po1 bloqué au monolithe ces cas
j pl est d'accord par exemple quand même
temps non je suis pas trop d'accord
j'allais dire je suis peut-être d'accord
si on parle d'un par exemple meego sous
ces deux outils de nouveaux rapports les
cheveux je peux
des phares le nom d'un gars qui est
décédé m'a dit maintenant d'un puits
même paulilles pips ça allait quand même
mais dont un ex extrême tension mt
paraître que c'est un frein à
l'émancipation de la culture noire parce
que le propos est un peu réducteur mais
en même temps si tu parles d'un point de
vue de ta réalité
je vois pas pourquoi ce serait réducteur
on laisse bensimon depuis une éternité
et peut-être que mon amalgame y est
dégueulasse mais j'aurais fait pareil on
laisse vins du monde depuis une éternité
écrire des tonnes sur la rupture
[Musique]
sur l'amour
fait partie de leur réalité nous qu'on
laisserait pas du mont écrire des tonnes
sur la réalité qui est de vendre de
cuisine et du crack pidal en vendant les
rues d'atlanta j'ai une caricature
complètement parce que je veux dire
c'est que ce propos le ya aussi
elle entendue c'est beau vrai que si je
trouve qu'on est sévère envers les
jeunes rappeurs particulièrement des 6
euros
si tu écoutes une tonne de djezzy est je
sais pas là tu es sûr que je faisais ce
drame un doute était ce son propos et
elle dit ils sont au cnes est venu avec
le temps affecté si tu écoutes et même
si ces mamies nine problème c'est quand
même ce qui sous tend cette affaire là
c'est un propos politique mais a quand
même une espèce de
une espèce de textes où il parle de
cette réalité-là dont les jeunes font
leur pain et leur beurre ou alors dit
dans la pensée là dessus est possible
pas nécessairement aboutir si chaud que
c'est un sujet qui est sensible
mais je pense qu'il faut donner à ces
jeunes rappeurs le temps aussi des deux
connectés avec leurs propres engagements
pis ça reste des jeunes qui réussissent
qui réussissent autrement qu avant
d'entrer dans la rue finalement feront
de l'ordre font de la musique c'est ce
qu'il faut faire dans les deux peut-être
de fausses mais dont on ne connaît pas
la raison pour laquelle on est peut-être
plus critique envers les jeunes rappeurs
c'est que djezzy wisson rockness comme
c'est devenu avec le temps mais pas
nécessairement juste le temps de lui
dans sa vie mais est venu aussi avec
l'époque l'époque même qu'avant si c'est
peut-être pour ça que maintenant je te
manque un eminem sort un album qui suis
encore le mot flag puis encore
l'homosexualité c'est peut-être pour ça
que maintenant c'est comme le mnm jose
ils jugent ils sont sûrement à lundi et
puis on n'est pas que c'est peut-être
pour ça je pense que le le jugement
envers les jeunes artistes est plus
sévère 6 1 par rapport aux gens qui
consomment cette musique là c'est parce
que je me dis hou
et oui ça va par exemple que j'ai pas le
smoker beck ou les pompes écrivain
tonnes complètement déjanté sur la
réalité vient d'en haut je considère
comme
des misogynes mais peu importe ils
écrivent une tonne
pilote il va aussi j'aime morency et le
moment si ce n'est un bon exemple le
mettons à brébeuf un pilote audi des
kids de bonne famille qui écoute et
chansons le qui chantait parole
c'est peut-être là où j'ai un problème
huit seulement de ce propos le dans la
culture populaire et encore une fois
comme j'ai dit ma réflexion impôts super
abouti là dessus et il faut peut-être
laisser le temps au talent et à 18 h
ma réflexion était définitivement pas la
plus structurée de l'histoire jusqu'à
audio aurions une tribune pierre en
public je veux pas m'arrêter là dessus
qu'ils sont venus me go sont venus au
festival d'été de québec est passé l'an
dernier où la deux
parce que le même été joe hickman ma
blonde et musicienne puis on avait joué
au festival étaient illégaux qui nous a
fait un lift s'ils font des livres
mettons de vannes de boostedge à 21
exact qui lui avait livrée nigaud ce
qu'ils étaient
les autres le plus jamais vu en effet ce
sera l'été sont impolis avec tout le
monde qui savent pas vivre na na nana na
na pi c'était comme seul un peu le
feeling général du staff du effet cupide
entre les branches de comme que migros y
avait pas de bonnes manières sommet of
course campbell mannhardt ils viennent
du viennent bien la même réalité que
nous autres le tri c'est notre réalité
c'est carrément été mal élevés comment
ce que je dis je comprends en même temps
je le sais projet connaît pas ces
gueules mais je me dis je ce qui est
surtout dans une posture août et 1
une personnalité publique doit quand
même une certaine décence à respecter
peu importe qui tu es peu importe quoi
te comprends mais on sentait que ça a
été un succès presque instantané parce
que je connais pas la loi début métier
je peux comprendre qu'ils entreposent la
ruade supporter internationale ça se
peut qu'un délit ce club qui quitteront
le bien faire bien faire social n'y
arrive pas instantanément
attends ouais en fait je le sais pas dit
mais je me dis juste et aussi une
responsabilisation de l'entourage de ces
gens là dessus je pense que ça vient de
nous quitter on s'entend que migros a
pas mal levée si je ne m'abuse kantchari
gambino a gagné son ami pour atlanta
sont promis pour la première saison et
qui eux ne dopent me gausse ni par
enbridge a eu un énorme succès
mais c'est déjà un succès dans le milieu
underground c'est jusqu'à ce qu'ils ont
été accompagnés de façon correcte
puisque tu peux apprendre à des gens au
cias comporter de façon décente
quand comme city le succès leur tombe
dessus
elle c'est pour nous espérer que oui ça
vient peut-être avec le temps ça vient
peut-être avec quelques échecs aussi
probable
gros débat quand on ne trouve des
brémois on est poète spécialiste de la
question mais on veut continuer de
réfléchir c'est intéressant quand même
si c'est souvent des discussions que j
ce qui est drôle c'est ma philosophie
par rapport à la musique puis certains
la trouvent vraiment naïve de motessus
je trouve que c'est une forme
une forme d'art
laquelle il faut donner beaucoup
beaucoup d'impôts parce qu'on fait avec
union c'est toujours moi je moi je crois
pas tant à la critique musicale de façon
constante et perpétuelle je crois à la
curation bon qui existe peu
puis je crois au contexte que tu vas
donner autour d'un artiste mais je crois
pas que le jugement d'un individu par
rapport à une oeuvre
sert le vaste public à part un public
averti et connaisseur de ski de ce qui
s'en va consommer de c'est mon avis fait
pour ce qui était mon opinion sur tous
et tous ces rapports le leur milieu mon
meego suis pas le plus grand fan
j'allais les voir au centre bell quand
c'était justement avec avec drake
c'est moi ça me rejoint peu
personnellement je peux comprendre
pourquoi la forme parle à du monde mais
je me concentre pas tant que ça à
réfléchir
c'est malheureux un but si l'ambiance
qu'on disait tantôt d'un exposé toit des
choses qui étaient qui confronte métier
je m'informe pote tellement sur les
débats autour de ces gens là parce que à
la base pour une musique quand la
musique s'arrête d'avoir des publics
cibles seppi puis le problème avec la
critique souvent c'est que c'est un
certain
j'en sois qui partage de certaines
caractéristiques soit de race ou
d'ajouter qu'ils interdisent au québec
ce qui fait qu est ce qui fait que tu
vas avoir des opinions plutôt uniformes
ou ce qui fait que l'expérience telle
expérience justement d'un jeune noir aux
états unis qui hurlaient certains propos
des migs sait ce qu'il veut s'il va plus
aimer ce que le que leblanc un
quinquagénaire qui déboîte ici c'est
normal d'affaires de public seppi même
chose pour un temps la musique
s'adresser mettons au gène c'est ce que
mes temps au jeune fille tu sais ce qui
m'attend à rien a regretté ce report
perçu du mobile a atteint un statut plus
de popstars de popstar est habilité sauf
qu'ils étaient mais tant que tu fais de
la musique dont le public cible ayant
des jeunes filles mettons adolescentes
et jeunes adultes mais que tous les
critiques de musique tous les
programmateurs de festivals
tous les gens qui ont une influence sur
est ce que ta musique est valable ce
qu'ils veulent avant tout non c'est des
gens qui sont pas du tout un public
cible c'est comme disait quand même
décalage s'est pressée
l'idée de faire de la musique pour un
public cible non mon fai malgré soi je
pense
j'ai créé une tonne il est probablement
certaines personnes qui partagent
peut-être certaines caractéristiques
avec moi ou non mais qui certain type de
personne ne sait pas trop qui vont qui
vont hurler et a subi d'autres noms
d'autres - mc culturel impression aussi
peu trop mais en fait mon problème c'est
plus à la lie à la création l'idée de
créer de la musique pour un public cible
particulier alors je pense pas que vous
n'êtes pas trop cher jean sasson
s'imaginent que ça existe cela dit non
mais attends un public cible malgré toi
une vitrine qui compose la musique c'est
sûr qu'il ya du monde qui trippent
classiques vont jamais aimé un artiste
et pops et mettons nous serons pas le
public sénat auront sûrement les mais
humble et mémé seront pas le public
cible de ce
il m'assure que les vases communique de
plus en plus simplement je me dis il ya
autant de gens qui quand on a commencé
pour la première fois à jouer par
exemple jean michel blay ya deux ans
qu'ils nous écoutent qui tripent sur
jean michel blais qui tripent sur la
tonne de tupi oued qu'on va jouer
moi je pense que je suis un gros samatan
dès 2018 et ouais je pense que le leader
quand ça sonne bien c'est bon c'est un
peu cela reste une question d'ouverture
aussi
puis je pense que sa réalité du contexte
aussi vite et moi je pense que plus tu
donnes d'une de contexte autour d'une
tonne sanctions deviennent trou
cérébrale mais tu parles des émotions tu
as vécu en l'écoutant qui dans le
contexte de création
tu parles de l'artiste plus tu donnes
des chances et des clés aux gens des
miss qui vont écouter pas un fan de lady
gaga mais quand j'ai entrevu en temps
d'une entrevue avec elle par rapport à
son dernier album
quant à la sortie louise est née avec
une loi des animateurs de radio
préférées
ça m'a porté à écouter l'album je les
écoute plus à ce jour mais ça m'a quand
même aidé de façon significative à
apprécier un comprend puis à comprendre
exactement la musique guelph et puis
pourquoi elle a fait la même chose avec
le documentaire par exemple qui ont un
effet sur cinq sur ce moment là dans sa
vie mais c'est ça un artiste maintenant
c'est plus que la musique est si l'image
qu'ils contexte puisque cet intitulé
représente que ce qu'il a à dire
côté valeurs c'est quoi c'est ici qu'on
bosse et qu'on gagne en même temps 6 6
et c'est aussi tout linverse parce que
quand tu parles des plateformes
numériques
c'est la dépersonnalisation de la saison
puis moi j'aime les deux tu penses que
je me donne des chances de donner des
artistes quand je lui dise à faire sur
pitchfork course sur un ami ou peu
importe mais j'aime aussi l'idée
d'arriver rindom dans un magasin sur ce
point les fans en champ d'un ami de
shahzad puis d'être découvrir quelque
chose sans aucun but en contexte juste
parce que ça m'a fait ressentir des
choses
à ce moment précis de ma vie je trouve
ce je trouve ça intéressant
je pense que les deux pôles doivent
exister force par un pool de mines
domine l'autre je pense qu'en ce moment
c'est justement ce qui est en train
d'arriver si on tenterait de verser dans
le diktat du streaming la playlist
rencontre la playlist exact cohérente
pid du son pour du son puis du bad sont
background pour du son de background
alors que je pense que c'est si on
considère un marc séguin comme une
oeuvre d'art à part entière faut qu'on
considère chaque chanson comme une
oeuvre d'art à part entière
quand il domine le respecte quel prix m
demandez quel shoot alléluia parce que
tous les postes avec nicolas hulot c'est
quoi j'ai jamais réussi encore à ce jour
avoir mené trois shows c'est très
étrange gjc jamais jamais jamais arrivé
encore je veux les voir je pense
l'impasse au balattou des soldats soif
commande je paye mes billets de
spectacle c'est vraiment très très très
rare que je ne serais ce que même
demandé une faveur à les voir un show et
je trouve ça trop précieux j'hésite pas
encore vu mais je me dis que ça va vous
au bon moment ce faire les choses sont
en tournée ça fait deux mois sont en
tournée de lula en fin de semaine était
à cannes fragments avec tendu de cuir et
d'un festival ça n'a aucun sens de
parler moi je les connais bien je
parlais que jesse qui est bassiste et
compositeur là dedans dit
allez décrire les ai juste dit m the
hills a plané sur youtube il est tombé
sur des vidéos manager est il fait donc
monter band il a dit m direct sur
instagram
imagine toi tu le trouves instagram les
messages de talent et de quiétude at on
ajouté
l'artiste c'est la beauté un autre en
chine mais c'est la beauté de l'art
numérique tu es une intermédiaire puis
besoin de 12 minutes de jeu qui se
parlent plus de 50 les bourreaux qui
essaie de trouver un arrangement tu es
artiste artistes après seulement
s'arrangeront parce que la décision est
déjà prise
c'est vraiment important il faut passer
les autres parce que vous parlez du
marché de musique hippie d'aubaine que
la musique est excellente et super bowl
mais l'image est tout aussi excellentes
sont en adéquation parfaite puis ce qui
a fait le succès du ben je pense que
c'est la proposition musicale
la proposition esthétique visuelle son
sens par ford et cohérente dans lequel
après ça j'ai jamais vu un spectacle
mais j'en déduit qu'en spectacle aussi
ça ce deuil parce que souvent je trouve
que ces deux étapes le sont de plus en
plus réussis de plus en plus cohérente
les nouveaux artistes mais souvent
houleux boblet td show j'en vois je sais
pas combien par mois le mettais tarifs
fait à
j'aurais tellement aimé ça que ce soit
exceptionnel sur scène
le tissu est assis un autre artiste ou
un autre ben générique qui va
fonctionner sur les plateformes
numériques - qui va jamais
nécessairement cros et en termes de
following de spectacles d'expérience la
mc2 ces deux 2 heures différents
vraiment donné un spectacle qui fait de
la musique c'est moi je gagne ma vie en
tant les spectacles depuis des années il
est temps qu'il vient le temps de
composants studio c'est comme si je
recommence pour recommencer à zéro mais
c'est comme c'est un autre trop de
travail sur un médium qui y en a pour
qui le studio sur leur environnement
naturel ou sont à l'aise puis la scène
un peu moins pire ne profite celle
inverse
il sait se mais quand commence à
maîtriser les deux manettes chose
justement
toujours été bon live mais le
le sahb avec son road et puis le choi
solide
vivendi avec le le apprécié quand tout
est bombée le sexe des limites lesaint
définitivement scellé les bonnes
personnes le bon entourage les bonnes
opportunités mais autres ça pour garder
notre autrement qu'ils aient les bonnes
opportunités qui capitalise là dessus
nicolas merci c'est vraiment le fun on
voulait commencer à faire des toupies tu
autour du cinquième épisode jette
remercie le buzz et on écoutait ou des
besoins directs ya six fait du bruit
ouais définitivement puis union union
pas mal ça ça fait que sur les liens
mois dans bio dans le bio les les
imprudents description des eaux
est-ce que les liens sont dans la vidéo
met son art view ouais merci